Unironically, this is our JFK curved bullet situation. >> The
FBI out here doctoring videos, setting this guy up to take the
fall, okay? And they just threw a random blue line on here and
they're like, "You know what? I I don't know. I can't fix it."
He's pretending to be a potted plant for days just for this one
shot. Okay. To me, do you really risk that with all of the cameras
there? So many people recording this Charlie Kirk event. You
risk having another shooter there who could get like recorded
and exposed. And I I just I can't see it, man. Yeah. People want
to believe conspiracies. Absolutely. And then you use your credibility
to reinforce conspiracies that you are clearly you've proven
yourself wrong on.
New Charlie Kirk evidence changes
everything.
Says Kyle Kolinsky
two days ago. All right. There's like been a slow metriculation
upwards of like some theories that bigger YouTubers and bigger
YouTubers are all talking about. Please don't tell me donuts
said it was the I don't think that happened. But I think it's
not really about who did it. It's about oh I don't think the
official story is correct. I think that's most of what I've seen.
I'm not sure. >> All right. Welcome to the show y'all.
We got a lot going on today. So yes, later on in the show I will
talk about the news that just came out this morning that there
was a mass shooting at an ICE facility where immigrants were
targeted. Uh there are three immigrants dead. There are no ICE
agents even injured. But given those facts, the right has still
decided to go allin on shamelessly lying about this. Let's start
with this. You all know um the Charlie Kirk story has not been
adding up at all. There's a couple things that I keep coming
back to that I just haven't seen a sufficient explanation for.
Uh, one of those things is that the shooter allegedly changed
clothes two times. Why he did it two times, nobody knows. Nobody
can explain why he changed twice and why he did it at the times
that they said he did it. Also, nobody can explain. They allegedly
uh disassembled and reassembled the weapon also multiple times.
Nobody can explain that this particular weapon is notoriously
very difficult to uh disassemble and reassemble. It's not really
made to do that easily. Uh nobody can explain how this particular
weapon even when broken down, it wouldn't fit in his backpack.
Nobody can explain how the weapon was reassembled in the woods
after the shooting when it allegedly was disassembled after the
shot was fired. Uh there's a lot that doesn't add up. Never mind
the uh multiple decoys that were in the audience that you know
I I there's no explanation that makes sense that includes those
people unless they were involved in the plot and the FBI is trying
to pretend like they weren't involved in the plot and in fact
those people have been let go. So as you all know I've had many
questions about uh you know what went on here. So I don't know
if like assembling reassembling the gun multiple times I don't
know. I assume he disassembled so he could get off of the campus
without the gun, like with the gun in his backpack, right? And
then he reassembled. I don't know why he reassembled later. But
I'm I don't know, man. Is there like a time I want him to go
through a timeline that he actually has here? And it seems like
I got to be honest, it seems like originally I thought I'd be
in the minority, but no, I'm not. I I appear to be repping the
majority position certainly among people left of center, but
even among people right of center. I know that MAGA certainly
MAGA leadership is trying to make this about Trantaifa. Blame
trans people, blame Antifa, but it's not working. And it's not
working because they keep trying to get away with preposterous
things. So, here's a great example of that right here. Fox News
tweeted this a couple days ago.
Man of steel, Charlie Kirk's body stopped a bullet that would
typically just go through everything and it was an absolute miracle.
Nobody else was killed, his surgeon told TPUSA.
It's so up of God to stop the bullet just perfectly kill Charlie
and nobody else. What did Charlie do? What What did Charlie do?
It is insane
that in the year of our Lord 2025,
they wrote this with a straight face. I mean, this is humiliating.
They're actually making the case that Charlie Kirk is unique
among billions of human beings and his uh flesh, his I don't
think they're actually making the case that he was unique. I
think they're just trying to lie and say like some crazy [__]
happened. I got to imagine that there are things that can happen
that cause a bullet not to pierce in the same way like literally
just a manufacturing defect.
I have no idea, right? Like there's got to be things that could
happen that would just make it so I but I don't know why we'
Anyway, so I'm I'm giving the I'm I'm mostly going to be like
looking to debunk here because I I feel like the official story
makes some sense to me. But well, I I won't listen. I strong
positions weakly held. Okay. If I see good evidence, I can be
swayed. I just I feel pretty strongly that the official story
seems most likely. I don't have any reason to doubt that Tyler
Robinson is the person who shot him. But his blood, his bones
are just that much stronger that they were able to stop a bullet
that others just would have no chance of stopping whatsoever.
Now, that gets to the main point here, which is the story they
were telling originally was, okay, the shot that hit Charlie
in the neck, well, first it had to ricochet off of a bulletproof
vest he was wearing, and then it went up, which is why the entrance
wound was so large because normally an entrance entrance wound
it is actually very small. Like, usually where the mess happens
is the exit wound. That's where you see, you know, wait, he had
a vest. I mean, he's wearing something that looks like some kind
of bulletproof vest, right? He does appear to be wearing something
that looks like a bulletproof vest. Sort of the flesh explode
and the blood come out. And so the the fact that the entrance
wound appeared to be so big, the explanation was, hey, the bullet
ricocheted off the top of his bulletproof vest. You could see
his nipples through his shirt. And then somebody says he a thousand%
had a vest. Okay, he's wearing nothing. You can see his nipples.
I Okay, dude. There's something going on there then >> and
sort of went in almost sideways or tumbling and that's what led
to the huge open wound and the >> blood immediately coming
out. >> But here's the thing. Erica Erica Kirk has subsequently
come out and said he wasn't wearing a bulletproof vest. Not only
that, but some people say um you know you could see in in certain
in certain clips from certain angles, certain pictures, you could
actually see a little bit of the outline of his nipples through
his shirt, which would again prove he's not wearing a bulletproof
vest. Oh, Kyle just said the nipple line. Oh my god, did some
people pre-watch the the nipple narrative has been spread amongst
all of the propagandists. Okay, I see you all in chat. I see
all of you.
Uh, actually, actually, you couldn't possibly have nipples on
a shirt. Okay, no such thing as Okay, so what's the It's a line.
Is it It's Game on Thrones. Sorry, it's Game of Thrones, right?
More use less useful than nipples on a breastplate, right? I
think it's Game of Thrones.
>> So, if you throw out the bulletproof vest aspect of
this, well, then you open up a whole can of worms. George Grmm,
bro, I don't know what I'm trying to say with George >> cuz
now it's like, well, that can't be an entrance wound anymore.
That looks like it's probably the exit wound cuz that reacted
like an exit wound, right? Okay. So, now uh all of And the funny
thing is, you know who's really making a big stink about this?
It's the right-wingers. because it's the people who are very
well-versed in gun culture and they know the facts and the evidence
and how these things work because they've been shooting guns
their whole lives. And so we have a bunch of people who came
out and talked about this and were like, "Nah, bro. This this
simply does not add up." So here's one right here. I want to
play this for you. Take a look. >> You know how many people
hunt out there and know exactly what a 306 round does to a an
elk skeleton or bone? We're not dumb. This ain't going to work.
The man of steel, his bone density. Let's talk about this. Okay,
let's talk about some things that aotics can do. From out to
about 4 to 500 yards, a 300 stick can penetrate elk bone. Why
is that significant? Elk bone is significantly more dense and
strong than human bone. Why? Because elk get up to almost 1,000
lbs. And so the bone has to be extremely dense to carry that
much weight. Now, let's compare it to human. Okay. Well, for
one, let's talk about where Charlie got shot. He got shot here
in the corateed. If that did hit a vertebrae in the neck, let's
understand that neck vertebrae is some of the most fragile bone
in the human body because it's so flexible to handle what we
do with our neck. So, what they're telling you is a 30 odd six
round which can blow through. Oh sh Oh, hold on. Am I the only
one who noticed this? There's no way. I'm looking back at chat
real quick. You ever want to see the drama that the special forces
influencers get into? This guy's good for it. Oh, maybe. Sorry.
Am I the I I can't possib Nobody said the word yet. Is nobody
seen Is nobody noticing Valhalla
in the background. Yeah. What the [__] How's nobody
noticed that yet? See you in Valhalla, brother. >> Oh,
was stopped. >> Oh, whoops. Whoops. >> By Charlie
Kirk's neck and a vertebrae. If you believe that, God bless your
little heart. Now, let's look at this actual bliss theft. All
right, so we're going to watch a video from US Overwatch. He
just put out this a day ago. Very good video. Oh, his name is
Valhalla VFT. Oh, is Cash signaling to us? Cash was going to
tell us who to >> Check it out. I'll put his link in the
pin comment if you want to watch the whole video. >> So,
our first shot will be a cold boore shot and we will just see
what kind of results uh we are able to duplicate. >> All right,
so he's got some very thick bone here across the strap of this
dummy. Obviously, this would be far thicker and stronger than
a human vertebrae in the neck. Let's uh let's see what this 30
oic rounds does to it. >> And that's not even the uh the
gelatin test. I know you've seen it with like gelatin and I mean
I've seen like the head get straight up blown off from a 306
round. Like this is not there's no
>> that the weapon that they're saying that they're saying
was used was used, right? It was definitely a different weapon.
Now at this point we don't even know where the shot came from.
More on that in a little bit. But dude,
Kyle's Kyle's like, I never shot a gun in my life. I hate guns.
I want all guns taken away. But these gun YouTubers sure are
smart right now. I'll keep going here. >> All right, from
that angle, as you can see here, not only does it go through
that bone, it explodes the bone, blows through the dummy. Also,
as we'll see here in a second, blows through the wall behind
it. >> Like we did kind of also think, the uh bone stood
no chance against a 30 caliber round traveling at that high of
a velocity. So now we're going to give it uh reset it back up
and put the uh ballistic plate in front of it and see if we can't
duplicate that shot as well. >> Right now, he actually
shoots a ballistic plate with 306 round. Destroy the plate. He's
there. just ripped the entire half of that plate off. What's
>> There you go, guys. You just saw I mean right there
for you. 30 odd six round damage it's going to do. Went through.
>> This guy is saying that a 30 odd six round no chance
that it gets stopped by a human body in any way. >> Way
bigger bone. >> Even with appears he's saying even with
a plated uh like a plate bulletproof vest, no shot >> than
a vertebrae through the dummy through the wall. Blew the entire
top section of that ballistic plate off. But Charlie Kirk's neck
>> the plate. Okay. >> Flesh and a little vertebrae
stopped that round. So now uh everything's in question. People
are saying the kind of gun is in question, the round is in question,
the the direction of the shot is in question. Uh basically people
are not buying anything. If the bullet just grazed his neck,
wouldn't that be a reasonable expect explanation
of what? Puffshake, hold on. Are you asking somebody else? Cuz
if you're asking just generally, I think the issue here is if
the bullet just graze his neck, there would be an exit wound,
right? If it didn't hit something that was stopping it concretely,
there should be an exit wound
thing. And if if all of us can look at what they're presenting
and rip it apart to this extent, what do you think a good defense
attorney will do? I'm telling you, there's like like almost no
chance whatsoever that Tyler Robinson is found guilty based off
what we've seen so far cuz their story does not add up. It all
right. So, do you imagine if he's found innocent if like the
story doesn't change? And didn't he confess? Only kind of via
texts. Only kind of via texts. There's no He's not cooperating
with them. He's not He went with the police and they he turned
himself in, but then apparently he's not cooperating with police
either. So, more now, like I said, all this is hitting a fever
pitch online. So, what happens? Well, uh the FBI director, Cash
Patel, he comes out and says the following. Ready? As the director
of the FBI, I am committed to ensuring the investigation into
Charlie Kirk's assassination is thorough and exhaust. >> Bro,
Cash was talking again. I didn't know Cash was yapping, pursuing
every lead to its conclusion. The full weight of America's law
enforcement agencies are actively following the evidence that
has emerged, but our efforts extend. >> Oh, everybody's
been saying the texts are fake, too. >> Beyond initial
findings, we are examining every facet of this assassination.
We are meticulously investigating theories and questions, including
the location from where the shot was taken.
Wait, hold on. So, that sounds like you guys are kind of admitting
the shot maybe didn't come from the front. That the original
story you tried to convince everybody of was complete and utter.
This is what he's saying. Hey, we're looking into maybe the shot
came from elsewhere. Wow.
Yeah. I don't know if Cash has ever watched any press conference
from another FBI head. Okay. But usually the answers that people
look for and the answers people get are not the same thing. Usually
the answers you get from a competent FBI head are we don't comment
on ongoing investigations.
Why? Because when you comment on ongoing investigations, one,
it creates a duty to to actually correct yourself. If you accidentally
get something wrong, you look like a incompetent rich to the
public. And two, it's because you don't want to feed any of these
people who are going to use anything you say as proof of whatever
their conspiracy is. I'm trying to find anyone talking about
how you can see his nipples proving no uh proving no vest. This
is all I'm finding. This is stupid. >> Uh well, let's keep
watching. I'm sure Kyle is a source. >> He says the possibility
of accompllices,
the text message confession and related
Discord chats, the angle of the shot, and bullet. >> He's
literally He's literally referencing every conspiracy theory.
Uh Hanchester's observed his potential signals near Charlie at
the time of his disaster. He's literally like we're running down
every conspiracy theory, guys. Why the [__] would
you say this? What What is the purpose of saying impact? How
the weapon was transported? Hand gestures observed as potential
signals near Charlie at the time of his assassination. This is
something I showed you, I believe, you know, right after it happened.
Okay, new stakes. All right. If James Comey is found guilty on
any of his charges, you execute him. If he's found innocent,
you put him back in charge of the FBI. Okay, that's that's where
we got to go with this cuz I swear they need James Comey. They
need somebody back who knows how to run that department. Jesus
Christ, guys. In my long segment on it, a lot of people isolated.
Looks like these people are given signals who are next to Charlie.
He says, "We're looking into that, too." Okay. And visitors to
the alleged shooters residence in the hours and days leading
up to September 10, 2025. Some details are known today while
others are still being pursued to ensure every possibility is
considered. Our primary focus is to complete this investigation
and deliver justice to protect the integrity of the investigation
and subsequent uh prosecution. We cannot release every piece
of information we have to the public right now. We will ensure
every question is addressed at the appropriate moment regarding
specific details such as questions about the plane that allegedly
turned off its transponder after departing from an airport near
the assassination site. We can share updates when answers are
confirmed. After interviews with the pilot and consultation with
the FAA, we determined the transponder was not turned off. Incomplete
flight data in rural areas cause the apparent gap. The entire
FBI mourns the loss of Charlie Kirk. We will not rest until justice
is served and our investigation into this assassination will
continue until every question is answered. So the thing about
the plane there, he's alluding to something we had brought up
that why is he doing this? Nobody knows, man. soon after
uh the there were plane they didn't shut down the airport. There
were small planes still taking off and one of those planes sort
of went off radar for a little bit. Basically, he's he's trying
to address all of the chatter online and the conspiracies and
people saying, "Hey, yeah, he's a this doesn't make sense and
that doesn't make sense." But okay, here's the thing. First of
all, you would have been the ones to fake the dialogue. like
you would the text messages you guys released. It sounds like
you faked it and I don't trust anything from the MAGA DOJ and
the MAGA FBI. I trust nothing from them. But furthermore,
dude, is there no Okay, I understand cuz I feel the same way.
Okay, I I feel the same way. But is there literally nothing
in these people's bodies that make them go, "Yeah, it was totally
insane when conservatives did this, but when we do it, it's totally
reasonable." He's like, "Is there nothing? Is there not a little
bit like h I just man?" And I think there's a lot of reason not
to trust Cash Patel and the the FBI like there's obviously way
less reason to trust them. The loyalty test and right um just
generally how incompetent he is, but a little bit it's like you
got to keep some faith, dude. You got to recover after these
people are gone or you got to hope for it. I don't know, bro.
This is why you don't put a podcaster in charge of an investigation.
Yeah, this is why you don't do that. True. This is why you have
seasoned veterans and experts who know this stuff uh to do this
stuff. They fired the top FBI person in this region of the country
not that long before the shooting happened. And now he's running
around like a chicken with his head cut off and his thumb up
his ass and he doesn't know whether he's coming or going. And
this is him just desperately trying to quell the online mob saying,
"Oh no, we're looking into it. We promise we're looking into
it." Are you? Are you? Because Tyler Robinson is insisting he's
not even the guy who did it. And now everybody's starting to
have questions about that. That he looks like a psy. Now it genuinely
looks like even where they say the shot came from, the shot didn't
come from there. That AAM's razor is the shot didn't come from
where they say it came from. So if the shot didn't come from
there, then there was just a guy there with a gun who had messages
apparently that the FBI found. Like you have to understand this
can't be AAM's razor. Aam's razor is the government faked this
guy. They set this guy up to be to take the fall for for Charlie
Kirk's death. That's not that can't possibly be AAM's razor.
That can't possibly be it, right? Like that's fullon government
complicity in Charlie Kirk getting assassinated.
That cannot be the simplest explanation no matter what, right?
So then it's like, okay, well, where the did it come from? Well,
I've seen theories, none of them particularly convincing, but
I've seen theories of like, oh, this person to the side of Charlie
did it. And then I've seen other theories that say, "No, no,
no. This other person to the side of Charlie did it." Then I've
seen theories of there's this guy in like
Wait, that would be insane, wouldn't it, Kirstki? That would
be nuts actually that like just coincidentally
two people showed up to do the same the same like decentralized
terrorism at the same time. And one of them like had the rifle
there. They were like set up and ready to go as they laid down
to take somebody else like dude. But then why is why is Tyler
Robinson turning himself in? Why is he not freaking out? Why
are there no messages saying I didn't? Right. I >> or why
would the FBI cover those up? Like that's that's the crazy a
corner and you know and very pixelated but you can zoom in and
see him from a distance. There's a guy with a sniper rifle packed
away in the tucked away in the corner. Uh so like people are
trying but I don't know. Nothing's really uh totally satisfying
here. But let me give you some more. So this was a video that
dropped recently as well. This guy has his own theory that he
wants to to share with you as we pro range day bro is the video
that this is going to be the video that Deepack watched as well.
Okay. And this guy is going to propose that Charlie was shot
from like a different place. Charlie shot in the back >> see
here in this segment or in the in like the back of his neck that
that the wound you see in the front of his neck is actually an
exit wound from a much smaller caliber caliber rifle. You're
going to see everything I've given you so far is pretty much
rockolid, right? Everything I've given you so far, >> the
fact that they're saying he's a man of steel. No, he's not. That's
the fact that now the story about the bullet and the gun makes
absolutely no sense. That that's a fact. And Cash Mattel is scrambling
and basically being like, "Oh, we're on it. We're on it." But
yeah, I guess we don't know. Okay. The the funny thing to me
is is like there are right-wingers like doing this and it's only
the people. Can I get Can I get donut operator to confirm this?
Can I get other gun tubers to confirm this? Cuz here's the crazy
thing. You'd expect all the right-wingers, if they all had the
same understanding of how guns worked, you'd expect a whole bunch
of right-wingers who are like special forces who have experienced
shooting people and seeing what the wounds look like, you'd expect
them to come out and go, "Oh, this is totally true." But the
people I see running with this are people who have never shot
guns before, like Kyle. That's what that's what's concerning
to me is I do see like conspiracy theorists running with stuff
but they especially the range day bro there are views on it but
why am I not seeing like donut operator assumptions run with
this yeah Brandon Herrera or or whoever all the guys who love
conspiracies a lot of the spec forces guys are questioning it
okay like okay maybe maybe there's just like uniformity there
and I just don't see it don't know what the [__]
happened either well now I'm going to go through here some of
the theories and we're going to start with with somewhat plausible
and then as we go on it's going to get into crazyville. Okay,
but let's go. Here we go. >> Ladies and gentlemen, I now
have acquired proof that the FBI's official story is false, whether
knowingly or unknowingly. We're going to have an entire monologue
and talk about a lot of these things after I show you this. But
>> I'll be totally real. There's a lot of people who are
in just the most confusing positions right now. You're a YouTube
sensor. You've just been told by Congress or you've just got
an order from Congress, YouTube has agreed to unban people for
political speech. There are right-wing crazies
posting videos questioning the Charlie Kirk storyline showing
that guy's neck hole in 4K for hours and hours and hours of footage.
How do you censor them? Do you censor them? Can you censor them?
Can you censor a 200,000 subscriber right-wing channel for speech
on a political assassination that's showing Charlie Kirk's neck
hole, right? Do you risk it? Do you not risk it? What do you
do? I feel like you're in like the toughest position in the world.
It's like, yeah, you should protect Charlie Kirk, but what what
about free speech, dude? Yeah, the YouTube must be losing their
minds about what to do about this, >> but if you take nothing
else,
>> you need to see this. >> And in that video, you
can see the same. >> So, the gore is stuff that's getting
censored. Nobody's showing like the blood coming out, right?
But they are showing like the hole in the neck, the exit wound
before blood is spurting out cuz that is one of the frames. >> What
appears to be the bullet coming down and it does line up with
the actual gunshot itself. >> Gang violence. So, this video
was created by a friend of mine who is a Marine. You'll see him
here at the end. This is the angle he is showing the shot coming
from, showing where Charlie was sitting and the angle of the
shot. >> Dude, am I the only one who's like, "This is disrespectful."
Am I the only person who's like, "Yeah, this is some disrespectful."
Why? Why?
I I'm sorry. I feel like it's like weird. I don't know. shot
which will correspond with this video here which unfortunately
we will blur out Charlie's face but we will show what >> Thank
god the only way they got away with this was blurring his face.
Thank god his facial features take up so little space. There's
barely any blurring but >> it's necessary to prove that
this wasn't >> I'm sorry that was a little distasteful
as well. I apologize. >> Entry and exit wound. So you'll
see him circle the highlighted area right there and you'll see
the exit wound corresponding after split second after as it would
from an entry and exit wound. So in this footage, >> so
like this is the everybody's reviewing this. Everybody's showing
it. I'm like, bro, this is like this is up. This is like this
is so [__] >> You can clearly see that Charlie
is shot from his back, right? And there's blood splatter coming
out of the entry wound immediately after a shot. The first arc
is kind of down as if it's just gushing out from the entry wound.
And then the second shot corresponds with when his head kind
of snaps forward, that fluid then flips up in relation to that
motion. So you can see there's that second splatter flipping
up into the air. This is something that I hadn't seen to this
date. I saw this for the first time uh late in the evening yesterday
and I decided that this need So there is somebody in my Discord
who is trying to do this right the uh the frame by frame analysis
here. Uh little spoiler for later. David Pacman finds this in
I think another angle and it seems like whatever this was is
not not what this guy's going to claim it is. >> Need to
be put out immediately because not no one that I know of is talking
about this. So, big shout out to my friend who actually found
this and created this video. You'll see him here in just a moment.
But let's just one more time look at this shot. You see bullet
comes in in that circled area. >> So, they're saying that
the the thing up there is the bullet. Okay.
And the entry wound is behind his neck. The exit wound is here
in front. Now, I don't know how anybody squares the argument
the 30 odd six totally obliterates the target like this, right?
And they're going to say that the Well, oh, sorry. Wait, wait,
wait, wait, wait. I'm I'm getting ahead of myself. They would
argue it's not a 30 odd six round coming from the other >> You
have the blood splatter go down then up and then immediately
after you see the exit right here with the skin being pierced
and then the exit wound emerges. And again, that is not a far
distance for a bullet to travel. Whatever the caliber is, whether
it be 5.56, 308, 306, it's not even a debate at this point. It
doesn't matter what caliber killed him. What matters is that
the official narrative is not true. again whether the FBI knows
or not that they're lying, but this is 100% conclusive evidence
that Charlie Kirk was shot in the back of the head and it exited
through the front of his throat. All of the evidence points to
Charlie being shot from his back right now, including this little
blood splatter that we can see here against the white backdrop,
the extreme hemorrhaging from the front of his neck, which again
corresponds with an exit wound, the extreme loss of blood, no
matter what the caliber is, that distance, that amount of meat
is not enough for most bullets to expand. I mean
9.9. So like I don't understand how this is% of bullets will
not expand in that short distance. Most of them require 12 to
14 to 16 inches even sometimes of tissue to expand properly.
Also Charlie tensing up correlates and proves that he was hit
in his spine. It's a spinal injury. Any of the game that I've
shot in the neck or in the high vitals where you where you impact
the spine, the game usually drops right in its tracks because
you sever the spinal cord. This >> So like watch his hair
jolt forward. This is proof that the head was struck from behind.
So, why are they censoring his face?
Trying to be respectful. Okay, they're trying to be respectful.
Trying to have a tasteful assassination analysis. Okay, >> it's
again exactly what we see with Charlie. He tenses up his head
also, his head movement also correlates with being shot in the
back of the head. His head snaps forward and then he tenses up
and you see him fade away, drop the mic, and um was absolutely
traumatizing video footage. And I'm sorry to have to um show
you guys this again, but but this needs to be seen and talked
about because this is going to be suppressed in the algorithm.
So, make sure you share this with any of your friends, your family
members, save this video, whatever you need to do. So, this video
was actually provided to the channel by um a friend of mine who
is a Marine and I forgot to show you the end of the video here.
So, this is my friend who actually made the video. I want to
just give him a shout out. I will link his socials down to the
>> I've been shot many times, three times and I know exit
and entry wounds. I have extensive firearms training inside the
Marines and civilian world as well. Appears that Charlie was
shot in the back right side of his head and the bullet exited
through his neck. The moment I saw the video and he tensed up,
I thought, hm, that looks like a head shot given the fact that
he seized up. It's a very common occurrence with a >> description
below. Again, he is the one who brought this to my attention.
>> Okay, so the stuff about it looks like he was shot from
behind and that was the exit wound. That honestly makes more
sense to me. Now, the the deeper question though is who would
have been there and had the ability to do it cuz it looked like
from most of the camera angles I've seen, it looked like there
wasn't much room for anybody to be there. Right now, he says
he brings up this portion here. I'll go back to it where you
know they say, "Oh, this is where the guy is shooting from."
But if this is where the guy is shooting from,
my understanding that was that this was more front right of Charlie.
This wasn't this wasn't back right of Charlie. This was like
front right of Charlie. So I don't know how they be front front
left. No, you could take a shot from there and have it be have
it enter, you know,
back here and the exit wound be front left. So I I don't know
the lines he draws a line here to sort of make it seem like oh
the lines work out. I don't know based on see he's drawing a
line here but my understanding
was that this line >> I'm like trying to >> if you
actually drew it properly toward Charlie this would be like a
front right shot at him. It wouldn't be a back right shot. So
I'll let it keep going here cuz then he does draws this other
>> How come no one was saying there they heard a gun from
that area
which sort of implies like Yeah. Oh, this is where it would hit
him. I don't think it is. I I think I thought that there was
uh that was more front right. So, parts of this it kind of makes
sense. The blood the tiny blood splatter coming out of the back
first sort of implies to me that that would be more of the entrance
wound, right? And the size of the wound in the front does make
it seem like it'd be an exit wound, but you don't know that at
uh Kyle Kolinsky doesn't know about this. I hate that he's pretending
he does. >> I'm not an expert. I'm not an expert. But the
terrifying thing is we can't rely on Cash Patel and the MAGA
FBI to actually get the right answers and give the right answers.
I mean, how hard did they try to pin this thing on trans people?
They tried so many ways. They, oh, it was a trans shooter. You
had uh 4chan doxing three or four different trans people who
didn't do it, by the way, trying to ruin their lives. Then they
moved it to, oh, there's trans stuff on the bullets. That's not
true either. Then they moved it to finally, oh, he's got like
a trans partner, roommate or something. So they kept moving the
trans goalpost, but obviously ideologically they just wanted
to blame the left. They wanted to blame trans people. So they're
blinded by their bias. So you can't trust coming from these people.
Nothing at all. But you know, people are starting to dig deep.
So this is one theory that went out there. This thing has has
gotten a lot of traction, by the way. A lot of people are talking
about this. Like I said, I've seen theories that uh the shooters
were directly to his side. I've seen different people singled
out as the shooter to the side. Uh but let me keep going here.
So, this is the other thing people have been talking about now.
Uh, they're they're what is this? Cope. Oh, you can't trust Kyle
Kolinsky now. Oh, I see. Well, don't worry. We've got a David
Pacman video coming up next. All right. We're going to see everybody
look through this. >> Going deep. We're going to see this
bullet go through Charlie's Kirk so many Charlie Kirk's neck
so many times. You guys will never want to watch this footage
again. Okay. >> On Erica Kirk and they're they're learning
more about her background. So, this person says, "Dude, there
are like hit pieces on Erica Kirk, too. Someone linked me a hit
piece on Erica Kirk." Hey, media, what are the odds of Turning
Point President Erica Kirk and Virginia prosecutor Lindseay Halligan
being on on the same stage in the same Trumpowned 2009 beauty
pageant? And so, you dig deep on bruh
bruh Lindsay Hallan. You guys do you recognize Lindsay Halagan's
name? Lindseay Halligan is who is
bringing the indictment. Okay. had the grand jury convened to
indict James Comey. That's Trump's attorney. That's Lindsay Helin.
What? Dude, the the there's like a solar flare in the schosphere
right now. There are so many alarm bells going off. Is going
nuts on Erica Kirk. And you find out that um she did the MissUSA
thing, the the Trump MissUSA thing. Uh, another thing about her
past,
she uh, apparently her mom, they moved to Phoenix because her
mom got in is wait is the is the nothing ever happens Chud getting
brutally like beaten to death like he's the printer from office
space.
The nothing ever happens Chud is just like every single happening
that ever could come to be is beating this dude to death with
a with a baseball bat in a parking lot somewhere >> involved
with the government. >> Also, that's a joke about a fictional
character. don't not actually violence or or condoning violence
in any way. >> She got a job with Homeland Security and
the Department of Defense. So, there's links between her mom
and the US government. People are all Dude, dude, dude, dude.
He's literally just asking questions right now. This is literally
like the This is right-wing conspirator like conspirator
like paint by numbers conspirator.
Isn't it concerning that these people were in the same place
at the same time at a different time years and years ago? Isn't
it concerning that this thing also happened? It's a little weird.
Is Isn't this strange? Isn't this just a little odd? Also pointing
out Erica Kirk uh apparently worked for this like Christian missionary
thing in Romania and the Christian missionary thing she worked
for in Romania
uh were allegedly disappearing children.
And you know that begs the well what the were they doing with
them? Is this some sort of trafficking thing like we've been
so concerned about visa v Epstein and stuff like that? And people
are making these videos, bro. These videos are first of all,
they're blowing up. But is this just going to be implying that
like Erica Kirk was Trump? Is that all Is that all Kyle's doing
right now? Kyle really doesn't care about his Kyle's Listen,
Kyle saw other people getting attention and Kyle's like, "No,
no, no, no, no. Give me that attention. Give me that attention."
right now. Second of all, it's one of those things where it's
like you can drive yourself crazy connecting the dots on this
[__] So, here we go. Watch this. >> Charlie,
I love you.
>> Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait. Is this a
satire video that Kyle's falling? There's no way this is satire
and Kyle's just falling for it. Totally. >> So, that's
her at a Trump MissUSA pageant. She did one in 2009. That's her
dots on this [__] So, here we go. Watch >> Run
it back. We're running it back. >> Charlie, I love you.
It's not it's not satire. It's
>> so that's her at a Trump MissUSA pageant. She did one
in 2009. I think she did one in 2012. This is her at the event.
Trump owns the MissUSA pageant that Erica Kirk Romania. This
is what I just told you about. Romania probes Israeli adoption
agency link in organ trafficking. What the Kyle is? Kyle's on
one right now. Okay. He's getting the involved in a totally unexpected
way. What the Oh, that's the other thing. She has told a story
about how her and Charlie met. I don't remember all the specifics,
but it was something like on a plane to Israel or in the airport
on the way to Israel or on the airport on the way back from Israel.
>> They're accused of training children in crime and sending
them west. We as the American people deserve to have every
That's where I disagreed with Charlie. I hate my opponent.
The $12 million fortune Charlie Kirk leaves his wife and kids
following the shooting. Bro, only 12 million. What? The $12 million
fortune Charlie Kirk leaves his wife. There's way more money
there as in like if they just if she just wanted to sell like
the controlling stake in TP USA. I assume it's I assume it works
through like like it's a private entity, right, of some kind.
Maybe it's a it's not a nonprofit, is it? like selling the rights
to this name and to this trademark to this organization would
be worth a lot. >> This guy definitely needs the music
from under her skin.
>> I can't do it with my voice. It's too much. It's a 501c3.
Oh, it's a nonprofit. Okay. Uh so you could still sell your controlling
stake in your nonprofit though, right? I believe you should be
able to you should just be able to say like transfer ownership
to somebody and set up like money to do that. No, you cannot
have shares. Wait, what happens then? Does a 501c3 have to have
like a board and then I I don't want to figure Listen, I'll figure
that out later. Okay, I'll figure that out later. I'll figure
that out later. Nonprofit and another Okay. Okay. >> Kids
following shooting. Nearly 5 million raised for Charlie Kirk's
family following assassination as Turning Point USA sees upwards
of 18,000 new chapter requests overnight. >> Are you still
talking about Jeffrey Epstein? This guy's been talking about
for years.
And are people still talking about this guy? This creep.
>> That is unbelievable. >> I was definitely trafficked.
Romanians adopted as kids now seek justice. Answers as adults
then. All right. Now we're going a layer deeper. Ready? We're
going a level level deeper here, bro. Oh, we can go deeper. We
can go. We can go deeper.
See, now we're getting into all the like the conspiracies I'
I've we've talked about to this point are more or less within
the realm of not insane. Now, we're getting to the sort of stuff
that the flat earth community, there are certain theories that
they are gravitating to about the shooting, and we're going to
walk through some of them here. So, uh, one of the things some
people are saying, dude, I don't know what possessed this guy
to do this, I think Crystal Ball,
Crystal Ball is like a very serious person. I I feel like she,
Bro, she's got to be like, is she not checking in on this guy?
Is she not making sure this guy's taking his meds? What is happening
with this guy right now? And to be fair, I don't know. By the
way, this is all in good fun. This can all be in good fun, but
just a little bit. It's like Kyle Kyle, if I was doing this,
I would get it. Okay, I I can do this. My show is like I joke
around about this stuff all the time. Kyle's supposed to be a
little more serious. I maybe not. Maybe I'm crazy. I don't know
if this one is actually flat earth. This might be just short
of the flat earth community here, but um they're saying that
the video of Tyler Robinson allegedly running across the roof
um that that particular video is AI that that's faked. And some
of the points people have made is that, hey, I thought that this
campus was just uh given a whole bunch of, you know, 1080 HD
security cameras and now you're showing us videos that look like
they're recorded on a phone from 2007 from 200 yards away. It
just doesn't that's weird. It's weird. And so people are saying,
"Look, this is this is uh faked. This is AI." And I'll play the
video here for you and we'll walk through it as we talk about
it. But take note here of the shadow of Tyler Robinson as he
runs across the roof. And the shadow disappears when he gets
on uh this portion of the roof. Watch. I'm going to mute it.
Did you see that? One more time. Running. There's the shadow.
Shadow is gone when he hits the white part of the roof. All right.
One more time. Shadow is there as he's running in >> Is
there no explanation for that? I Is there really no explanation
for that at all portion when he gets to the wipe? >> I
guess I I guess I just have to ask cuz I the white portion. >> It's
exposure. Yeah. Like if it's if it's a highly exposed, it feels
like this could happen. >> Brightness and exposure. Maybe.
Rooftop CCTV is edited. Rooftop CCTV. >> There's a shadow
disappearing again. >> Bro, Kyle is all in with this dog.
Kyle's thrown his thrown in his credibility with this adorable
dog that's doing conspiracy videos. Okay. >> Shadow disappearing.
They're going to get to another uh discrepancy in the video that
they say. >> Watch here. They say vertical lines glitch.
Why is he reading it like we're reading it? Why is he reading
this like he's watching it for the first time? Did he not get
convinced by this stuff before he decided he was going to go
cover it? Or is he just like chilling? He's just big chilling.
He's like, "You know what? Send me the conspiracies. I'll look
at him. I'll do a live react. People who think the moon landing
images are fake point out zero visible stars. It's because the
exposure from the surface of the moon lit up lit up bright white
is drowning out the stars from the image." Oh. Oh. Oh. >> Okay.
That one was weird. Let me watch that one again. I didn't quite
see this one. Did you guys notice anything here? Let's see. Running.
Running. Running. Going to zoom in on the lines. I guess those
lines change a little bit. Blue haze on the edge of the roof.
That I don't know about that one. The blue haze. The blue haze
thing just seems like, bro, the FBI out here doctoring videos
setting this guy up to take the fall. Okay. And they just threw
a random blue line on here and they're like, you know what? I
I don't know. I can't fix it. Cash, can I just put this video
out? Cash, can I just hit publish? I can't fix the blue line.
There's just a blue line. Okay. Okay. Again, if this one's a
camera, you could just have weird glitches. You know what I'm
saying? I don't know why the blue haze. Okay. All right. And
then the person behind the tree is the other one. You're going
to see this. So, see this person walking, walking, walking, walking.
They get behind the tree and then they don't finish walking.
It just stops. They're going to show it again. They're rewounded
here. They get behind the tree and then they stop. >> Oh,
the dog is confused.
>> The dog is confused.
Okay. I The dog's confused. I'm confused. >> Found it here.
>> Look at this adorable dog.
>> Uh, excuse me. Excuse me. What the The dog's confused.
I'm confused. What is happening? Is Where'd that guy go? Where'd
that guy go? That one. That one. People were pointing out that
one within like the first week. I think this is Hold on. Google
Earth lo.
This is actually flat earth stuff, isn't it? This is actually
flat earth stuff. This is Why would Kyle make this video? Can
anybody explain why Kyle would make this video? I'm convinced
Kyle really does have zero foundation now and could be a flat
earther.
I That one dog versus world at dog versus world. It's a flat
earth dog. It's a flat earth dog. That one people were pointing
out that one within like the first week, I think. Bro, I wondered
what happened to Wishbone. Anybody watch Wishbone when they were
a kid? What's the story? Wishbone. This is what happened with
Wishbone. Okay, Wishbone didn't die. Wishbone fell down the conspiracy
This is if you zoom in on the video to the right hand portion,
you see somebody walking on the sidewalk, but when they get to
behind the tree, uh they stop and there is no they don't continue
walking through the other side, which I mean another explanation
for that is the person stopped walking, right? Like maybe they
stopped and they looked at their phone or some [__]
Um, but people are using this as evidence of, hey, this is like
AI. This whole video is faked. Whoever's putting together these
uh these edits with this dog, they are uh
they're all in, huh? Google Earth Loi Center. Let's see.
>> Oh, Loi Loi Center. I got it. Google Earth Loy Center.
They look at the top of the building. Oh, I'm wrong. >> I'm
wrong. That was not what I thought it was. I should have known
Losi Center was the uh >> CCTV had clear view footage not
released. So, they're saying the footage was not released of
You can see in this in this uh in the screenshot here,
uh the the full video of it, you would be able to see the shot,
but they didn't release the shot is that point that they're making.
That That's what they're trying to say there. Um all right. So,
now now let's go fully into Crazy Town. Let's go fully into Crazy
Town. This is um people were pointing this out within the first
week, and it was one of those like I don't know, man. obviously
some optical illusion or some but people were saying oh the whole
event is faked and one of the reasons is watch what happens to
the chair after Charlie gets gets here a chair goes through a
table and like it it looks like you know you know what would
be the absolute like worst case here is the palm pistol one I
I'm a bit worried okay if I get convinced I shouldn't I shouldn't
even go after Kyle okay because what if I get convinced
should be like a little more open-minded Right. What if I what
if I go through all these things? I'm like, Kyle's a total. And
then by the end, I'm watching like dog clips tomorrow. I just
come back, I'm like, oh my god, you guys. This dog versus world
thing. This account is this account is so much more credible
than I thought. A chair literally like goes through a table like
it's some some video game type glitch. So, watch this. Here we
go. Watch the chair. Wait for
There's a chair and it goes through the table. You see that?
You see it? One more. Wait, that Wait, what? Time. Watch the
chair. It sort of goes through the table. Right through the table.
You saw it one more time. Chair through the table. I lied one
more time. So I'm chair through the table. >> Hold on.
Hold on. Hold on. Hold on. I lied one more time. Chair.
Hold on. >> So legs are out. So legs are facing this way.
One, two, three, four legs. The chair is not The legs are not
Okay. The legs are like facing out towards us. Okay. They're
projecting out towards us.
And it falls over. It looks like it goes into the table. Okay.
>> I'm guessing that right here the colors are matching
close enough that you can't see that the arm of the sorry, the
leg of the chair leg/arm of the chair is like on top of the table,
right? >> Oh, you think it just breaks?
>> I don't know. >> One of those stackable chairs
for easy storage. It doesn't have four legs. It has two. Okay.
That That's like I don't know. Just some optical illusion type
[__] I would imagine. You know, yeah, but because
All right, now we're going fully. We're all in. Now, notice the
name of this Twitter account. Brett Flat Earth Bible Jesus. Brett
Flat Earth Bible Jesus is going to tell us about the hologram
projector. Kyle. Kyle, what are you doing? Kyle,
what are we doing now? >> Brett Flat Earth Bible Jesus.
Look, the reason I'm showing you guys all this is not to be like,
"Okay, at least Kyle knows. At least Kyle knows how absurd that
is. At least he can identify it. This is what happened. It's
to show you all the stuff that's out there because nobody can
trust MAGA. Nobody can trust Cash Patel. They're they're useless
and they're biased. They have their own things they want to blame
it on. And so in the vacuum there, everybody rushes in with their
own theory. And now we arrive at the granddaddy of them all,
which is Charlie Kirk is hanging out in Cuba with Tupac. And
uh the whole thing was a hologram and he's still alive. Ready?
So I'm going to click play on this one for you. This one obviously
I think is just out there in Narnia, but nonetheless, it's interesting.
So let's watch. Good afternoon everyone. Now I'm sure all of
you have noticed online that a lot of people were talking about
why are these people allowed to be in this canopy? Why isn't
this marked off and taped off as a crime scene? And why is this
guy in the white shirt taking the most very important camera
down? The what do you think is the most important camera there?
Why is he taking it down? Well, here's why. Because it's not
a crime scene. A crime didn't take place here and that's not
a camera. Now, before >> Dude, this guy's got the voice
of an angel and he's doing conspiracy videos. That sucks, man.
>> I tell you what it is, I want you to get a real good
look. >> Yeah, I know. It's the Bubba Ray McCoy voice.
I know. I can hear it. >> Let me just say, I love how they
put like the spooky music in the background to have that subtle
psychological effect on you. Like, you know, I'm about to drop
some real on you, bro. As he's taking it down. Anybody figure
out what it is yet? Okay, here's what it is. It's called a hologram
projector. And if you don't believe me, you can go look them
up online. And they're not cheap. They're not cheap. Usually
20 to 60 70 $80,000 for these things. And they come in different
varieties. Now, Hollywood calls them hologram
stage projectors.
Now, you see how Charlie's little tent there is a perfect square.
>> And you, as you can tell, it's 10 foot squared, 10t
all the way around on each square, and it's about 9 ft tall.
That's because it has to be for the projection to work. >> I
didn't realize that I'd full screen this. Sorry, I'm trying to
figure out. >> Let's explain. >> The smaller spaces,
the projectors can be configured with mirrors to elongate the
projection path and maintain picture integrity. Eyeliner
displays ideally require a minimum footprint of 10 ft square
and a height of 9 ft to show full-size human figures. What you
are seeing is a reflected image which is so true and realistic
to the original, it has become known as a virtual image. Many
people perceive what they are seeing now as a 3D hologram. In
fact, it is a 21st century take on a >> now century visual
effect known as Peppa's ghost showing now on the relay
>> Call me crazy. >> Thanks in part. Do we not do
we not literally have people like on every side of this? We have
people at every side of this taking video from every side of
>> The amazing optical properties of the eyeliner foil
combined with the light and picture output of Christy digital
highdeinition projectors. The image has depth and opacity that
actually supersedes the scale and definition of traditional 3D
hologram. >> Like I said before, 10 ft squared, 9 ft tall.
This canopy was made this size for >> like I said before
10T squared. That's how you know. That's how you know it's one
of them projectors >> purpose because it is a hologram
stage projection that you guys were watching. >> These
performers are holograms. >> Every series we take one step
closer to achieving all of the sci-fi dreams. >> It's pretty
cool. You'll never have to miss a gig again. The gig can come
to >> We traveled to Paris to meet Ian O'Connell, director
of the company that put this show on. I recall we were being
asked to produce a >> So, you get the gist of it. But yeah,
they're saying the flat earth people are saying it was a hologram.
Charlie's still alive. Uh they go on in this video and other
videos to point to the fact that there's allegedly a trap door
that was right underneath Charlie. So, um dude, it's actually
like a movie. Dude, Charlie Charlie Kirk just prestiged you.
Okay.
Charlie Kirk just prestiged you. We to watch that. Somebody find
us the trapoor video right now. Okay, right now. I need the tra
I need the trapoor video. I'm telling you, man, it varies. It
v the different conspiracies out there vary. But the fact of
the matter is everybody is looking for answers because it's very
clear that the FBI has lied to us. It's very clear they're not
telling the truth. It's very clear they're not even really interested
in finding the truth. If I'm being honest with you, they want
to pin it on some Antifa person or some lefty or some trans person.
and uh you know move on and call it a day and use this for their
political ends, namely as Trump is doing, wage a war on the left
in this country. That's what they're doing. But they're you know
it's podcasters running the FBI and they're failing miserably.
And so
he feels no irony being like as a seasoned podcaster I am in
a perfect position to criticize the podcaster running the FBI.
He feels nothing. He's there's no introspection there at all.
He literally That's what you are, Kyle. You are a podcaster.
What [__] are you talking about?
Certain things. Uh, not that not that I think the FBI has uh
is >> You're more practical than other things. Certain
things make more sense than other things. This stuff here obviously
I have seen.
>> Well, now JSTLK, don't you go clicking away. Y'all are
scratching the surface of the truth in my video. Don't be scared
to look behind the sea. >> Behind the curtain. Don't be
scared to look behind the curtain. I will not bother Ray McCoy.
I will not be scared to look behind the curtain. >> Yeah,
I think is bonkers and totally out there with the >> stuff
that makes sense is um
that the official story is is bogus. It's completely complete
nonsense. It's just utter horseshit. And now people are correctly,
I believe, questioning where the shot even came from and what
weapon was actually used. So that's where we are now. And uh
people are going to keep trying to put stuff together and come
to their own conclusions because again what we're getting from
the government is just not even remotely believable at this point.
Hey y'all do me a favor and like and sub ma fascism is here.
What the this thumbnail Kyle will never be silenced. Okay. He
left the Grock icon in here. Awesome. Awesome. Me click on this
real quick. >> Welcome everybody to >> Oh, it is
just Crystal and Kyle. Okay. Cool. Cool. Cool. Coco co. All right.
I have the Range Bro video here. I was going to watch this before
I go to the DACA video. Yes, I >> ladies and gentlemen,
I now have acquired proof that the FBI's official story is false,
whether knowingly or unknowingly. We're going to have an entire
monologue and talk about a lot of these things after I show you
this, but if you take Okay, so this is a different Range Bro
video than the one that Kyle watched. All right, this is an updated
Range Bro video from although from 4 days ago. Weird. But there's
a couple different Range Day Bro videos. Okay, range day, bro.
Hold on. Let me look. He's got what? One, two, one, two, three.
So, there's one that came out yesterday, but we got to watch
that after the DACA video. >> Nothing else away from this
video. You need to see this. >> And in that video, you
can see the same what appears to be the bullet coming down. And
it does line up with the actual gunshot itself.
>> Gang violence. Great.
>> So, this Oh, wait. No, no, no, hold on. This is the
video. This is the video that Kyle watched. >> This video
was created. >> Okay. This is the video and it actually
it up. So, >> oh, this is the part that didn't go
>> Hold on. Kyle didn't go all the way
>> We We'll watch the whole thing. Okay. >> In that
video, you can see the same what appears to be the >> I
don't know exactly what Kyle skipped. We're just going to watch
the whole
>> Line up with the actual gunshot itself.
>> Hold on. Hold on though. Billy Joe Bush apparently has
found the trapoor video. Give me a second. We got a trapoor video
>> He got shot and that's >> Oh, so minutes after
he shot is shot, TPUSA starts to take cameras down, remove the
tent, etc. By the next day, construction workers tear out bricks
and foundation, removing the last evidence of the crime. Oh my
god, there was a trap
door.
Wait, let's watch it again. >> He got shot and that's >> dude.
Okay, I can't I've got no controls on this video, but I got nothing.
I got play and pause, but it was It looked like it could be the
same place. [__] Facebook does suck. Whatever. Whatever.
It you [__] me Facebook. We're back. Back to the
range video. >> So, this video was created by a friend
of mine who is a Marine. You'll see him here at the end. This
is the angle he is showing the shot coming from showing where
Charlie was sitting and the angle of the shot which will correspond
with this video here which unfortunately we will blur out Charlie's
face but we will show what is necessary to prove that this was
an entry and exit wound. So you'll see him circle the highlighted
area right there. >> Watch this part here >> and
you'll see the exit wound correspond
to go ahead and check him out. >> And I really >> I
think Charlie closes the video out. So, sorry, Kyle, closed the
video. >> Appreciate him sending me this over because until
he sent this to me, I just hadn't seen anything like it. Now,
I wanted to be sure and I wanted to make sure that wasn't like
doctorred footage. So, I went to one of the original videos that
I saw posted the day of Charlie's assassination. And right here,
I have it paused where you can see that splash that I'm talking
about from the entry wound. And you can see it slowed down. This
guy in this video is actually talking about the F in this on
his shirt in the ring. Some some other stuff that really has
nothing to do with it. People arguing about body armor. You could
see Charlie's ch, you know, his nipples through his shirt, his
chest, his >> The nipple narrative. Here it is >> through
his shirt. But you can see that he has uh no body armor on right
here. Okay, this would all be one slick piece of plate. It's
already been established there's no body armor. So, this is actual
proof right here. He slowed this video down perfect. You see
the blood right here dripping out of his head from the entry
wound and the bullet is coming from here down through here. Okay,
hit play. And there it goes. So again, I wanted to confirm the
footage I had seen originally was not in fact um doctorred in
any way. >> That's his earpiece flying off. I believe it's
like something. It's like a clip on. I I believe that. But listen,
we'll we need to consult the conspiracy theorist first. Okay.
>> So you can see it here as well. A little piece down
there. And it actually goes up a little bit off frame here um
for my screen recording. So you can see clearly entry exit then
you know of course the part we can't show here on YouTube. >> You
just showed it. >> So irrefutable evidence that he was
shot in the back here on YouTube. Clear as day to me. Now, that
may be a hard pill for a lot of you to swallow. And without doubt,
the non-player characters who just buy into the narrative, as
well as the thousands and hundreds of thousands of bots will
likely attack me in this video because I'm showing the truth.
I'm going to ask for you guys to share this video so that this
word gets out so that more people can see the truth of what happened
to Charlie Kirk. I want to take a look at this photo next. Uh,
this guy is talking about this bush up here in the top left of
this photo and he zooms in on it and he's stating that it does
look suspicious. It does look suspicious. It looks like there
is >> Brh brh brh brh br br br br br br br br br br br br brh
br br br bro br br br bruh what are we doing? What this bush
listen is where's the bush? This bush
this bush right here. That's a sniper bush. Okay, that's a sniper
bush. >> And he zooms in on it and he's stating that it
does look suspicious. It does look suspicious. It looks like
there is a person right here and it looks like there is a rifle
right here. Uh that the person is holding a hand here. Support
hand. Dude, what the [__] Okay, listen. Listen. That
guy walked in here with a ghillie suit to pretend to be a plotted
a potted plant in the background of some videos. Okay,
he's he actually came in in a ghillie suit. Let's go. >> Sort
of um very blurry image, but you can clearly make out this is
not just a bush. This is a
human skin tone right here. And >> you can clearly make
out this is not just a bush. You listen, it was a very blurry
FL, but you can clearly make out that that is not just a bush.
>> And uh this correlates with a human >> bro. Are
people trolling? This has 6.3 million views. 6.3 million views.
Okay. >> Hair and a rifle in the exact kind of crucifix
shape of an AR-15 with an optic on it mounted up. So, uh, good
on this dude for finding this photo and, uh, looking for, like
you said, hours of going through photos and videos until he saw
this. Uh, this would 100% line up with the actual shot that we've
now proven, uh, was not taken from the front, was taken from
the the back side of Charlie. This would line up exactly with
that bullet trajectory and the entry and exit wound uh, that
Charlie that we ex >> No, no, no, guys. You don't understand.
and he would have to show up like 48 hours ago fast while holding
his rifle perfectly still. Okay, he's pretending to be a potted
plant for days just for this one shot. Okay, >> exhibited
that we saw here on on camera. >> And you don't realize
it, but he's actually still sitting there right now. >> So
guys, this is a very heavy topic. I do not want to believe that
this is possible that the FBI either knowingly or unknowingly
missed this. And uh I'll leave that up for you guys to speculate
on. I'm not accusing anybody of anything. All I know is that
100% Charlie was not shot from the front. It is very clear that
he was shot from the side. Most likely by this bush up here,
this man in the bush, whatever you want to call him. It has been
very clear to me that there has been a lot of NPCs, a lot of
people going after me and others who are trying to seek out the
truth. And it's so important to not let them silence your voice.
Uh for Charlie, for for this country, really, for the Constitution,
for everything that we stand for, for freedom, it is imperative
that we continue to ask questions and seek the truth when we're
so clearly being lied to. So, I really appreciate all the support
that you guys have shown me over the last week and uh and trying
to uncover the truth. And all I would ask is for you guys to
share this video. Let me know about your thoughts uh down in
the comments below. Please head to Range J. >> Okay, this
is the video that we're going to watch. Now, our buddy David
Pacman, he's a little more circumspect. Okay, more suspect.
>> He does not trust these videos anywhere near as much
as Kyle Kolinsky does, okay? But he did do a video million views
day ago. >> Today, I want to start with a new viral video
making absolutely bombshell claims about the of Charlie Kirk.
The video is by a YouTube channel called Range Day Bro.
This is like a gun enthusiast of some kind. The video is called
Kirk Assassination.
Huh? A a gun enthusiast of some How did Wait, is Deepac like
an investigator? Can we get this guy on the FBI crew? All right,
this guy's a gun enthusiast of some kind. How did you figure
this out?
New video evidence changes everything. And this video has quickly
amassed millions of views. As of this moment, nearly 6 million
views. Now, this was not something I necessarily planned to cover.
Uh, but dozens of you have asked me about the video. You've looked
at it, and many of you have said, "David, I can't really find
any holes in what this guy is saying." And unlike other challenges
to the official story, I think it's at least worth covering.
Now, I'm going to be honest upfront.
There are claims in this video that I cannot definitively refute.
But it's really important as we look at these things to ask ourselves,
can I definitively refute this
versus,
is this proof of what the person in the video is alleging? And
those are two very different things. >> Uh, Pacman does
a better job of being responsible with this than basically anyone
I've seen. Like seriously, take a look. Okay. >> Sometimes
we end up, you know, in religion we call it the god of the gaps.
Sometimes we come up with something we can't yet explain and
there is a group of people that say, "Oh, I've got the answer.
The answer is God or an intelligent designer." And of course,
just because we don't have an answer to something, doesn't mean
that the answer has to be whatever the next person proposes.
So, I want to go through it. There is one primary claim here
and then a subsequent one that I'm going to look at. Now, I I
want to also I want to do this with care.
I don't want to show liveaction video of Charlie Kirk getting
shot uh or the gory parts of the shooting video. So, let's give
it a shot and and kind of see where we can get to. Now, the official
story of course is that Charlie Kirk was shot by Tyler Robinson,
who was positioned. If you're looking at >> Oh, guys, I
just noticed we got 36 minutes left on the stream. We are I think
we got to be 10 subs away from another two hours. Okay, you guys
want another two hours? 10 subs. Let's go. We can get there.
I know we can get there. I believe in you guys. Let's go. >> Sitting
the way Charlie Kirk was. Um Tyler Robinson was positioned across
and slightly to Kirk's left on a rooftop. So, we've got an image
from the Guardian here, which shows where Charlie Kirk was sitting.
That's the bottom left of the image. and where the shooter was
on a rooftop across the quad slightly to the left as Kirk as
he looked out at the crowd. So like if you were >> Yeah.
Kyle Klinsky didn't even get that right. I knew it was like front
left of Kirk, not front right. >> In the crowd looking
at Charlie, this would have been over your right shoulder, but
Charlie Kirk was of course facing out. It would have been ahead
and slightly to Charlie Kirk's left. Now, that diagram
that coincides perfectly
with the location of this horrible, gory blood spurt of Charlie
Kirks from a bullet that was on the left side of Kirk's neck.
Right? In other words, if the shooter is ahead of me to my left
and shoots at me, it makes sense that that would hit the left
side of my neck. I'm kind of reenacting the angle here. However,
what this new video argues is that this penetration in the front
of Charlie's neck on the left. Hold on. Someone just sent me
a tweet. Okay. From do we remember? I know you remember cuz it
was like two seconds ago. Lucas Jason Ted, thank you for the
seven months. I know you guys remember because it was like five
minutes ago, but you remember Brett Flat Earth Bible Jesus.
Okay. I'm being sent a a picture of one of his tweets. Okay.
The bottom of the rabbit hole. But why does he Why does he do
the brackets on the tea like this? The bottom of the rabbit hole.
Rabbi rabbi hole. It's every time. Thank you, Kyle Kolinsky,
for helping me find another anti-semite to follow on Twitter.
Thank you, Kyle. Thank you, Kyle. Thank you, Kyle. Oh, boy. >> Was
not actually where he was. >> Play the song. I'm not playing
this >> What this video is arguing is that that in fact
was the exit wound. And the claim is the bullet entered the back
right of Charlie Kirk's head, exited out through the front left
of his neck. Now, that would be a completely different scenario
than the official story. And in the video, and we're going to
look at it's really frames of this at this point in time. In
the video, Range Day Bro slows it down, zooms in, and identifies
what appears to be an artifact. He says it's the bullet entering,
hitting Charlie Kirk in the back right of the head. So, as I
play this, you will see that there is a moment where the red
circle is drawn around something to the back right of Charlie.
>> So, you see why I had to actually watch the video with
you guys cuz David is being very careful with this channel. >> Kirk's
head.
And the argument is that is the bullet entering. And if you continue
moving the video forward, you ultimately see uh in the bottom
right of the screen, it's sort of covered by these YouTube elements.
You see a uh let me see if I can even show you this more accurately.
There it is. You see the um what what we thought was the entry
wound of the bullet coming from Tyler Robinson.
Range Day Bro argues that that is actually the exit wound. Now,
first and foremost, does this >> I'm letting David cook
here for a second, guys, just because we watched the full video,
but you you're going to want to hear how David is like looking
at this to listen to when he's trying to debunk here in a little
bit. >> Contradict the official story. Yes, it does. For
the bullet to exit from the left front, it has to come from the
back right of the head. Which >> uh Jay Dog, are none of
these people going to ask themselves a very obvious question?
Why does his head and neck and chest get suddenly thrusted backwards
as if pushed from the front if he got shot in the back? Um, some
people say like if you got hit in the back of the head that that
like you see the head go forward first, but I Yeah, >> would
contradict the location of Tyler Robinson on the roof across
the way. Now, you all know that I look for the differential diagnosis.
I'm going to play devil's advocate and there are a bunch of different
questions here. Could it be that the artifact behind Charlie
Kirk's head in the video is not really the bullet? Well, yeah,
I think I think that is possible. And I'm going to suggest to
you in a moment that that may actually be the explanation. Could
it have been a ricochet? Could it have been um an unexplained
but unrelated artifact in the video? All of these are possibilities
for sure. However, I did find another video. This is a video
from a YouTube channel that is called Lifting the Veil. It has
only a thousand subscribers. Okay. And in this video, what you
see is that indeed that artifact by Charlie Kirk's right ear,
which Range Day Bro claims is the entry of the bullet,
looks like something completely different. And this is very slowed
down. And you will see there it is in these two frames. You see
that whatever that thing >> Hey, give me uh one second
here. I'll be right back. Give me >> is by Charlie's right
ear sort of goes up and away. I believe that whatever that is
is what range day bro is claiming to be claiming to be um the
uh entry of the bullet. Okay. I believe that this in the red
circle that we're looking at in the range day bro video is the
exact same thing. this vertical white line that you see in this
video. And um I I I hate to sort of be gruesome, but you also
see in this video that the bullet appears I'm not going to play
it a bunch of times. You can kind of it's just starting to get
gruesome, but you can go and look and you will actually see what
appears to be the bullet entering from the front as is the official
story and then sort of lodging itself uh seemingly in the back
of >> David is protecting his channel. Okay. >> Charlie
Kirk's neck. So, from this angle,
it seems to contradict what Range Day Bro is arguing. I don't
know if that thing we see flying off of Charlie Kirk's right
ear is an earpiece. I don't know if he wore an earpiece during
this event, these events. I don't know what it is, but when we
analyze something like this, we have to ask ourselves, okay,
what was the official story? What is the assertion that someone
else is making? In this case, it's Range Day Bro. And is there
another interpretation? Range Day Bro presents this as if there
is no question the uh uh artifact behind Charlie Kirk's uh right
ear is the entry point of the bullet. The neck wound we ultimately
see is actually the exit wound. We at least have one other video
which would suggest no that's not what it is. That artifact is
you know I don't know if it's shirt fibers. I I don't know what
it is, but I am telling you that I can't definitively say what
Range Day Bro is saying makes ultimate sense to me. So, this
is now for you to investigate and for others to kind of think
about. Now, I want to talk about one other thing related to this
video. Later in the video, Range Day Bro points to something
that others have mentioned, which is that if for a second we
were to to to imagine that rather than being shot from the front
across the quad by Tyler Robinson, that this bullet did come
uh from behind or sort of to to the right at a backwards 45 degree
angle from Charlie Kirk. There are people who have pointed to
what appears to be a plant. It's sort of in the at the top um
middle of Range Day Bros video here. And there are individuals
who have said that is not a plant. That is a person sort of dressed
like a plant. It reminds me of the San Francisco Bush man. This
is a guy who used to dress like or maybe still does dressed like
a plant on the Embaradero in San Francisco, the fisherman's warf
area. And people would walk by and the plant would jump up and
would scare people and it would lead to viral videos. The idea
I think from some is that this is actually a person disguised
as a plant. And Range Day bro actually goes further and suggests
that you can sort of see the outline of someone holding a long
barrel rifle with a scope. I do not have any reason to think
that that's what this is. And again, something being blurry and
being unable to say exactly what that is can't immediately suggest
to us that it is a hidden shooter. And I'll be honest, even though
there is this general idea that if Kirk were shot from behind,
this is roughly where the person would be, I don't even really
know that the angle adds up. Now, am I convinced of any of this?
No, I'm not. But what I am doing is dozens of you wrote in and
said, "What's your thought about this? It seems so open and shut."
I don't know that it does. And the questions that I have are
number one that we see this artifact kind of fly off and away
from Charlie Kirk's ear uh in other videos and it certainly does
not look like a bullet entry wound. And in fact, from this video
from behind, you see that there is no entry wound on the back
of Charlie Kirk's head. It would it would seem to debunk range
day bro's claim although I'm open to having my mind kind of changed
here. And then with regard to uh you know the plant person I
just think it's not dispositive one way or the other. I mean
look at okay so we went through the secondary artifact here right
the plant person. But he goes through like another channel which
I will go through in just a second. Okay. I do have that channel.
We can go check out some of these other videos. Some of these
other videos produ like they propose way different way way different.
Uh okay. Candace Owens debunked the shot from behind. She saw
the video from the guy who took it down. If it was not blood
it was not blood but his necklace flying behind him. Yeah. I
mean it seems pretty obvious that from some of the other videos
that are out there it was not. It was literally like not at all
>> on the back of Charlie Kirk's head. It would seem to
debunk range day bro's
>> like yes there are shots of him from that side and you
don't see the entry wound from that side >> although I'm
open to having my mind kind of changed here and then with regard
to uh you know the plant person I just think it's not dispositive
one way or the other I mean look at the plant behind me and just
because of the lens that I use which has an f-stop of 2.8 that
plant which is
Is this the obvious and only way to interpret this? I could,
you know, hold >> Even the plant behind me could hide things
or look different at the level of blur that it is. But just because
you say, "David, I think you've hidden a Game Boy in there."
Uh, I don't think that we could definitively say that one way
or the other. So, that's my view about this viral video from
Range Day Bro. I uh um think that the much like >> there
there no there are a bunch of videos out there. There are a lot
of videos out there. Okay. Now I I would love could somebody
ask
I want to know what convinced Z. That's what I want to do. Okay.
Can I see what convinced Z that Tyler Robinson didn't Charlie
Kirk? That's who I I want to know what she saw. Okay. can I see
the video that Z do you think Z saw the trapoor video? And she
was like, "Oh, of course, of course." Like with the claims from
Nathan Taylor in the Election Truth Alliance, the first step
is always understanding what are the claims. The second step
is verifying whether we agree as to what the evidence or or exhibits
are. And then only then can we go to the third step of saying,
is this the obvious and only way to interpret this evidence in
the context of the claim? with the range bro claims. I certainly
don't find myself convinced and I think the primary issues are
different angle shows no entry wound in the back of Charlie Kirk's
head. I don't even know for sure. I I want to say one other thing.
I I think just here very quickly. I don't even know for sure
that if the bullet did enter where range day bro is arguing that
it would exit where we saw the neck wound. I I don't even know
that that's actually the right physics. and angle of it. >> The
only thing is is so for all of this stuff, you'd have to I feel
like you have to go to some conspiracy theory
that like involves the whole crew that does the cleanup and because
realistically if you have this like as just another shooter who
fires a shot from somewhere else, you want to blame it on Tyler
Robinson, okay, or something.
To me, do you really risk that with all of the cameras there?
So many people recording this Charlie Kirk event. you risk having
another shooter there who could get like recorded and exposed
and I I just I can't see it, >> So, that's where I'm on
it. I want to hear from you. Leave a comment if you like this
sort of you know, we've done the election truth analys. >> Also,
nobody complaining about the shot. Like the shot rang out and
nobody's like, "Oh, the shot rang out from behind him." Obviously,
I haven't seen that >> Investigation earlier this week.
Now, we're looking at the claims about Charlie Kirk. If you like
this sort of analysis of I don't want to call them conspiracy
theories, let's call them alternatives to the >> No, Pacman's
mostly engagement baiting and saying I it seems like you could
debunk this with other videos. Kyle Kolinsky fully bought in.
Okay, Kyle Kolinsky 100% bought in. Kyle Kolinsky is in. He shows
me videos from conspiracy channels and it's [__]
>> official stories that we're getting. Leave a comment,
like the video, let me know. info@davidpacman.com.
There was a time when public education meant What is this? What
is this is an ad? Nah. Nah.
Nah. Nah. I'm good. I'm good. Okay, hold on. I was sent a clip
of Mr. Dioro and then I've got a Candace Owens clip. Hold on.
Where's my This is my Dioro clip. Oh, I can't look at my Dioro
clip. Hold on. I need my streamable. We'll do the other one first,
but I got to upload this. One second. One second. One second.
We got two clips and then we're going to move on to a little
bit more some of the other angles and
All right. All right. But then I need my I need my Candace. Here
it is. >> Okay. I didn't want to >> I don't even
know what this is, but somebody linked it to me. Okay. >> Okay.
I didn't want to leave you guys on a crazy weekend cliffhanger.
I needed to get that information out as soon as possible. Obviously,
uh you can probably see that I received some information, a communication,
uh which answered a lot of questions that the public has had
about the story or rather the non-story that we are getting from
the feds. Um the push that, uh Tyler Robinson is this lone shooter,
which they're uh trying to establish as a fact. Um some of the
burning questions that we had, okay, well, if he turned himself
in, how did he also not confess? I now have the answers to that.
Uh the main point, the reason why this
>> I will have more on this later, but I wanted to immediately
publish that the Tyler Robinson
narrative plus the dad that did the right thing after realizing
he was his son was guilty is a federal concoction. Wait, what
is he like apparently or something or
what's going on? Lots is going on here. information came to me
is because there is a narrative being spun right now by the media
that Tyler Robinson is or was.
That is not true. And that's a very scary thing when suddenly
they're saying he's and you know he's in solitary
um and he's not
wait.
It's been reported that well hold on. He said he was right off
the bat, but he said he said he didn't want to. So that was the
reason why this information urgently came to me. >> I I
feel like he was like on the day of and that was brought up,
but it almost makes sense. >> Obviously, I know a lot more
and I'm going to share it with you guys on Monday. I just wanted
to vet some of the things that I heard, ask some more questions
from people that would know. Um, and just to make sure everything
I say is above board. And obviously this lead led to more leads
and I want to give people a chance to respond.
Um, this is crazy. Nothing more that I can say. Uh, this is this
is very serious. >> He's implying he's a well, tons of
people are implying he's a psy. Ben Stellar. Uh, I don't know
if you've seen it, but Z Cohen Sanchez of UN America fame also
believes he's a psy.
So, I want to see this is like a person who, you know, I I would
just want to see what convince her. U, but her, Kyle Kolitzky,
there's a lot of people who are buying into this stuff. Candace
Owens.
So, somebody from every coalition under the rainbow. Okay. >> Yes.
I don't know what's going on, but I do know that what we are
being told has gone on is just not so. And um yeah, this is really
kind of going to be a
>> I think to answer a lot of >> Hey, Marty Epste
with the five gifted. Let's go. Thank you very much, Marty Epste.
Appreciate it, dude. >> Questions and many more questions
that need to be asked. So, um, I just wanted to let you know
that what they're telling us about him being is not true. >> Okay.
So,
so
from there, all right, we've got the Candace. Oh, hold on. The
Nick clip is going to be finished. This is going to be totally
unrelated. This Nick, this is Nick watching the completionist.
It looks like >> until I had >> I got sent this and
I was told you have to react to this. >> Until I had those
final results in my hand, hence my silence all this time. The
honest >> by like every YouTuber who claims they reported
like material to the FBI and posts a video a week later like
everything with the government takes [__] forever.
Like obviously that's just performative. Like you're saying you've
done that performatively. >> Final results. >> What?
What did I misunderstand what he just said he's not cuz that
on its surface without me doing any more thinking that sounds
like he's throwing Willie under the bus super hard for I have
no idea what reason. I have to listen a second time. Maybe I
misunderstand material to the FBI.
>> What is this? What does this guy say? >> Hand
hence my silence all this time. The >> By the way, every
YouTuber who claims they reported like Cam material to the FBI
and posts a video a week later. Like everything with the government
takes forever. Like obviously that's just performative. Like
you're saying you've done that performatively. >> Final
results. >> Does he just not think about like the I I we
all know how that ties into the Willy Mack thing, right? I'm
Am I crazy? I whatever it's fine whatever I don't dude I don't
know I don't know what's going on there that's baffling okay
so we're going from here now before we go into the next video
after the David pack >> ladies and gentlemen >> we
got a brand new Range Day bro video now
150,000 views somehow in my head I'm like I'm guessing Willy
Mack posted same day not a week later yeah I just I have no idea
Uh, I have no idea why he would do that with respect to Nicholas.
I just don't get it at all. So, this video I'm guessing with
only 150,000 views, like did he did he what did he do? Did he
say that like oh no, the the mainstream story the the what is
it? The the prime narrative is probably correct. Cuz all I could
think here is he's correcting some misinformation. That's why
it has no views. If it was sensational, still kind of supporting
a a different narrative, I feel like this would have millions
of views, too. >> Welcome back to the channel for another
Real Talk episode. It brings me no pleasure today to continue
the discussion of the Charlie Kirk assassination. Obviously,
a horrific and tragic event. In the last video I put out on this
attracted a whole hell of a lot more of attention than I ever
expected. So, thank you to every single one of you guys who liked
and commented and shared that video. Uh, at the time when I put
it out, I was 100% convinced of certain things that we may have
new evidence contradicting directly. Actually, we do have new
evidence directly contradicting one of the main claims in that
video. I don't think it absolutely negates all the other claims,
but we're going to go through that and discuss it today. Um,
and and show you guys exactly what the counterpoints were to
my argument. And I really don't even want to call it my argument.
It is just a theory. I'm not married to any one theory, guys.
I'm out here trying to discover the truth just like all of you
are. And if I am wrong in that theory, in that video that I put
out, I will be more than willing to admit that I'm wrong and
show the evidence and the proof that I was incorrect and set
the record straight. So, today we're going to talk about it.
Again, I don't think this evidence disproves that theory of the
of Charlie getting shot from his back, right, completely, but
it does disprove uh one part of it, I believe, which is the blood
splatter that I believed I was seeing. Turns out it's most likely
Charlie's necklace. And let's just go ahead and show you guys
the footage here. So Jesse on fire is he showed my video um the
one that you guys have all seen by now and he is showing this
new camera angle again. I saw this camera angle but it was much
more blurry when I saw it and I wasn't 100% sold on it at the
time. People >> new camera new camera angle just dropped
>> or saying it was an earpiece, but I had seen multiple
other videos. You know, let me show you guys that first because
I don't know what this guy's name is, but I'll put it in the
description below. But he is talking he has a very good analysis
and I watched this after I posted my video to be very clear.
I had never seen >> the recon prep guide. Force recon scout
sniper. Oh, an actual sniper. Okay. >> This angle before
or this hypothesis of the earpiece
>> ex sniper debunking craziest Kirk assassination conspiracies
part two of
>> I I'm going to need an illusionist to come along and
debunk the trap door. Okay, that's the only acceptable that's
the only person with the expertise to respond. Otherwise, I I
am fully bought in on the trapoor theory. Okay. After I posted
the video, I watched this video where he goes through and talks
about how he does not see any earpiece on Charlie Kirk and I
concur. I agree with him uh in his analysis because you >> Don't
worry, Porter Beller. I'll pull up the I'll pull up the hologram
one at some point. >> You can see it on his security guards.
You can see it on his security team, but you cannot see it on
Charlie himself. As you can see right here, he points out that
a security team is wearing an earpiece. And you'd very be you'd
be able to clearly see it from this angle. Maybe not from the
front or even from the side as much, but from the back here you'd
be able to clearly see the earpiece. And he does show you can
see again here he's showing a very clear angle. There is no earpiece.
So without >> So the black square there. Is that just his
shirt? Cuz I would have I could have sworn that would be like
a clip-on mic or something like a secondary source mic going
to like a like a stream, some kind of video setup, right? Some
streaming or recording setup. But I don't know if that's I think
it might be a part of the show. does show. You could see again
here he's showing a very clear angle. There is no earpiece. So
without dragging this issue out any further and alluding to an
earpiece and and there being an earpiece there not being there
was not an earpiece has been confirmed by Candace Owens and she
confirmed he was also not wearing body armor. So those are two
facts if you want to call them that. She was told directly by
TPUSA or by Eric I can't remember by trusted sources that he
was not >> Wait, am I crazy or is Candace Owens not accusing
TPUSA of him? Now, I could have sworn I saw that earlier today
that Candace Owens was officially like essentially saying TPUSA
killed him. >> Not wearing an earpiece and he was not wearing
body armor. So, if you believe that, I clearly don't see an earpiece.
So, that's very simple and easy for me to believe that. Um, so
most likely, >> am I doing misinformation right now? >> What
we see blow off and what I was thinking and what I was calling
blood splatter from the back right side of Charlie's head is
most likely his necklace. And it looks and seems to me that it
has broken apart >> frame the f >> right here.
Skip ahead a little bit and you'll see. >> Okay. So to
me, does that frame not just literally show that frame right
there?
That shows
the entrance being through his neck. Although something else
is happening here with this blowing back like this. This seems
like it's got to be going through his neck, right? Like like
from the front. Like what's blowing the shirt back this much
>> right here? Let's let's let this skip ahead a little
bit and you'll see
there it is. You can see it's broken apart. So I've paused it
perfectly. >> But then again, hold on. But also probably
his shoulder blade pushing out like that pulling the shirt up
maybe. Okay. But it was like hunching >> here where you
can see his chain clearly snaps off down here in the front. So
it lifts his shirt up in the front and lifts his shirt up in
the back. It it snaps and it comes up and it looks like an earpiece
because of that angle on it. Also, this would correspond with
the video footage that I showed as the blood splatter because
you can see how it's >> So, he's basically, like I said,
he's basically doing a video debunking himself here. He's showing
exactly why his video is wrong. That's why there's no views on
it. Nobody cares about having their views corrected, right? That's
not his fault either. That's just I can tell from how much people
wanted to watch it that as soon as they're like, "Oh, you're
just saying you're wrong. Oh, close you." Right? Is that not
insane? There's like 6.5 million views on the other video and
then people see this video and they're like, "Oh, I don't I don't
want this corrected. [__] >> It's bent that
way and it could be bent down and then it would be bent up here
in just a second. Obviously, it's going too fast for this video,
this this camera angle to catch it >> just to be that's
not even like 100% what's actually going on. It's like the it
doesn't catch in the algorithm because people don't watch as
long. They go, "Oh, you're debunking yourself. They probably
close. It doesn't get as much watch time. YouTube doesn't serve
it and all of that shit." And then it continues on back and you
can see it back here. Again, this line right here across this
gentleman's shirt, you can very clearly see a wire which people
were assuming was the earpiece, but it's very clearly his necklace.
So, was it the shock wave of Charlie's neck being hit either
from the front or his neck and head being hit from the back that
simply lifted up the shirt in the back or was it the chain? I
would say it's probably the chain based off of what we saw in
the front, which is very clearly his chain breaking and lifting
up his shirt. So, I think it's more likely that pop. >> So,
this this pop in the back is actually the chain >> pop
in the back that Jesse's attributing to the the >> I think
that that to me also
probably concludes that or would lead me to conclude shot in
the front because the chain is exposed from the front, not as
exposed back. >> Inertia from the >> bullet hitting
him in the neck like >> I I guess it could be from the
exit wound too. pushing his back like the back of his shirt out
just doesn't make any sense because the bullet according to the
official narrative does not have an exit wound. It's still It
was found directly under his >> Yeah, but the I would assume
the chain snapping and like snapping violently causes it to pop
backwards, right? Where it snaps, there's like some force transferred
through that chain could explain why the it could explain some
of the lack of neck wound, too, right? >> Skin, which is
another thing we need to discuss. The man of steel theory, which
is like >> sorry, neck wound, exit wound, >> gaslighting
at its finest. But I I just don't see that puff. >> Wait,
hold on. just doesn't make any sense because the bullet according
to the official narrative does not have an exit wound. It's still
it was found directly under his skin which is another thing we
need to discuss. The man of steel theory which is like gaslighting
at its finest but I I just don't see that puff as being attributed
to uh confirming that the shop was from the front. I just don't
see the logic in that. Right. We're not we're not really trying
to stretch the imagination. That's what the official narrative
is doing. I'm trying to explain it in the simplest terms. Aams
razor. what is most likely to have caused this this injury in
the way that we saw it and that in the front seemed to me to
be pretty definitively an exit wound. >> AAM's razor, >> but
we're going to talk about >> a lot of people really really
abusing the out of AAM's razor as a term today. No, people just
people propose whatever they want to think and they go it's AAM's
razor. No, it's not. It's not AAM's razor. The thing you're proposing
involves a massive conspiracy within the FBI to get to frame
this guy's a pathy. I'm sorry. You have to have like really really
solid proof to get me off of the FBI like following the investigation.
Just just following the investigation where it'll lead all of
the uh evidence for and against the original theory, right? Because
the original theory was that we saw that that gush of blood out
the back right side of Charlie's head. Now, we can see that that's
not blood. In fact, that's his necklace. So, we're kind of back
to square one. We don't have any like 100% smoking gun proof
at this point because that's confirmed to not be a blood splatter
there, but we're going to talk about again both reasons for and
against the theory that he was shot in the back and for against
again that he was shot in the front of the neck. And I'm going
to do my best to address these guys. Again, I had so much coming
in. A lifetime is not enough time to address every single one
of these. So, uh, we also talked about body armor. Candace Owens
has dispelled the body armor claim. Uh, the bush shooter. Okay,
so in this portion of the video, I take a random >> the
bush shooter, dude. The fact that he he pulled up this bush,
this two pixel picture of this bush. It was like, so this is
clearly a human right here. It's like clearly the silhouette
of a rifle.
>> photo from the internet here. And I put this guy here
to show what it >> No, this is a video of this guy debunking
himself. Simpo, it's not it's not a debunking. It's him debunking
himself based on some other people showing photos. look like
if this image had been cleared up and if if in fact there was
a person sitting there with a rifle aiming down at Charlie. This
is not a depixelated version of what is here. This is not like
in the movies when you see like enhance enhance enhance and you
just like this emerges from this blur. That's just not how photos
work. This is something that I got off the internet for for reference
for you guys. This is has nothing to do this man was never at
the crime scene. Neither was this rifle. And a lot of other evidence
points to it happening from over here much lower. In fact, if
the FBI came out with a convincing story that was actually >> Wait,
what? Who's never at the what? >> And you just like this
emerges from this blur. That's just not how photos work. This
is something that I got off the internet for for reference for
you guys. This is has nothing to do. This man was never at the
crime scene. Neither was this rifle. And a lot of other >> Wait,
did somebody was somebody like, "Oh, RJ bro said it's this guy."
If they tried to find him or something >> evidence points
to it happening from over here much lower. In fact, if the FBI
came out with a convincing story that was actually like somewhat
believable, I don't think I would have ever even gone down this
path.
this guy's this is this is crazy. Uh, listen, I only talked about
the Bush man because the FBI lied to us, okay? It's the FBI's
fault that I did this. >> I'm not a political channel.
I talk about guns here on the channel. though. It is just impossible
to wrap your head around a 30 odd 6 entering right here at the
front of the throat, whether it was from a angle of elevation
or not. It is so impossible. And I'm going to show you guys this
video because this uh perfectly coincidentally lined up with
my uh timeline today. So, I'm going to show you guys this video
right here, which is exactly what happens when a 300 6 enter
enters a ballistic gelatin head. >> So, today on Dual Liberty,
>> his lawyer sweating off camp maybe >> firearms.
We're going to be showing you what a 300 6 does to a ballistics
gel
>> And before people call on this video, this video was
produced five years ago. So, this guy had no idea how relevant
his video would be today. In fact, a lot of the comments are
like talking about how uh this dude disproved the FBI's claims
before he even before they were even made public. Um, so anyways,
big shout out to these guys. What is this? What's the name of
this channel here? Dual Liberty Firearms. There you go. >> Dual
Liberty Firearms. absolutely smoked. Very similar looking bolt-action
rifle to the one the FBI claimed was used. Um, you can see very
clearly >> they're showing that there was a head shot.
Yeah, the head exploded. Kirk wasn't hit in the head. >> What
happens when a 300 6 enters soft tissue. So, if they want you
to believe that Charlie Kirk was the man of steel and this was
a miracle that God stopped that bullet and it was just under
his >> Yeah. I think all these people are like, "Oh, they
they said there was a miracle." I think probably they're just
trying to like add to the story. I'm guessing somebody they didn't
like do a lot of extra looking. They probably were just like,
"Oh, well, the bullet did stop inside. We don't need to know
why.
He's He's a miracle. It was a miracle. God saved all those people
behind him. Charlie gave him his life so that all those people
behind him would be saved. They just want his memory preserved
in like a a lionized way." It's pretty easy to understand. >> Show
us the bullet. Show us the autopsy, guys. show everybody the
proof that makes us say, you know what, case closed. That crazy
22-year-old did it. I want to see that. I don't want to believe
in this grand conspiracy that our government is the has the capability
to do this or to turn the other to turn the other way when somebody
else's government does it. Not implying anything. I don't know
anything at all. Again, the more I learn about this case, the
weirder things get. This is what happens to a human head that
has and ballistics gelatin is not one for one. Obviously, this
is as close as we can get, but you can see that >> what
happens.
>> The head that had literally blown the head to pieces.
There was not much blown the head to pieces. >> Let's see
if we can pause that >> right there, guys. If he got hit
in the side of the neck, what was stopping his neck from blowing
out that even just one side, let alone an exit wound? Let
>> Guys, this is this is 100%. This is what would have
happened to Charlie Kirk if he actually got hit with a 30 odd
six round. Okay, this is just it's just proven. It's just proven.
Why didn't they do the autopsy? Did they not do an autopsy? I
feel like they did I feel like there was some kind of forensics
report done. No, that would be pretty insane for a guy to get
assassinated. They don't do any kind of autopsy or anything.
They just bury him. That would be nuts. people who are talking
crap in my comment section, my other video saying that I am not
I I'm a I'm a product of the left. Like I'm trying to get this
guy off. I got no dog in this fight. The truth is the only thing
I'm after. And again, >> you're an unhinged leftist. Uh
can I see your Do you got any furry in your browser history?
You're You're very suspicious, sir. Have you ever seen any infl
Do you know what inflation is? I'm I need to figure out what
you're Well, I don't know what's going on here. more than willing
to admit when I'm wrong if new evidence comes out that is convincing
enough. But the more time that goes by, the more it seems like
this evidence is very convenient. Like the screwdriver, for instance,
they claim that Tyler Robinson assembled and disassembled his
gun and then to get it up there, then assembled it to take the
shot and then disassembled it to leave and then reassembled it
in the forest, but he left the screwdriver on the roof. So, how
did he reassemble it in the forest? Again, the story is beyond
belief. Let's just put it that way. That's why we are out here.
That's why everyone that's why that video resonated with so many
people. You could point to one thing and say, "Oh, he was wrong
about that." I'm just simply pointing out the thing that looks
like a duck. It walks like a duck. It might be a duck. That's
all I'm saying. So, let's get back to my video where we're going
to debunk or offer the other side of the story. So, we've already
addressed the bush man, the bush shooter. Okay. At the moment,
I had seen it. That looked a little convincing. Now, I do have
my
photos pulled up here. And this is a picture I want to give credit
where credit's due. John Cullen said, "Resolution matters." Dude,
dude,
it's clear. Okay, guys. Okay, guys. This is clearly a face right
here. This is clearly a human face. Okay, this is a rifle right
here. This is a face. This is a rifle.
Come on, man.
Come on, man. What the bro?
This now I just want to What did this guy think was going to
happen when he was saying insane?
That's rough. Okay, hold on. I got to go. We got to go open up.
I just got to We got to do this back to back. Hold on. Hold on.
Hold on. Hold on. We got to go do this back to back. All right,
we got to go find the other video right now. Where is it? Where
is it at? >> Ladies and gentlemen, is this coming from
here? >> Show me bush guy. Show me bush guy. >> And
he's stating that it does look suspicious. It does look suspicious.
It looks like there is a person right here and it looks like
there is a rifle right here uh that the person is holding a hand
here, a support hand sort of um very blurry image, but you can
clearly make out this is not just a bush. This is a human skin
tone right here. And uh this correlates with a human head and
hair and a rifle in the exact kind of crucifix shape of an AR-15
with an optic on it mounted up. So uh good on this. >> That's
so clear, right, dude? It's not even clear from this photo either.
Okay. It's so clear. It's so clear. And then you get to this
guy like actually actually viewing it. >> Debunk or offer
the other side of the story. So, we've already addressed the
>> I want to I want to debunk or offer the other side of
the story. >> Bush man, the bush shooter. Okay. At the
moment, I had seen it. That looked a little convincing. Now,
I do have my
photos pulled up here. And this is a picture. I want to give
credit where credit is due. John Cullen said, "Resolution matters.
Problem solved." Yeah, but is this the exact same photo from
the exact same? Again, I'm not even saying. Dude, he's coping.
He's actually coping about this still,
bro. Bruh, he's actually Dude, it's the same guy. The same black
shirt guys in the same spot in both videos. It's like the same
dude. Can you see the glass? The guy got sunglasses behind him.
It might be the same still at a higher resolution. bruh my brother
>> saying that the the Bush man was the guy who shot him.
It doesn't appear that it would line up perfectly or at least
ideally for that situation. It would line up but not perfect.
But again, like what do you think the shooter just going to be
hanging out there? That's not my hill to die on. I don't care
if it was the Bushman or not. I care more about what happened
than truth. So if this disproves the Bush theory, fine. So be
it. Do I still think it was probably from his back? Yes. So let's
go back to the video. In this footage, we can see >> again
what I originally thought was blood splatter. This is most likely
his necklace snapping. It flies up in the front. This is most
likely his necklace right here as well. It flies up, probably
snaps around this area somewhere. This side comes up and over
and back as Charlie falls to his left. That's another thing everyone's
like, he got shot in the front cuz he fell straight back. He
didn't fall straight back, guys. I want to show you this footage
real quick. This is my buddy's video once again, and he shows
this footage right here. I'll blur whatever is necessary, but
you will see the trajectory, the direction that Charlie's body
goes in. It does make sense getting hit in the back of the skull
right here. Charlie is struck and then he falls in the direction
that he was shot. Yeah. Now, he does lean back, right? I mean,
but a bullet whizzing through your head and neck that quickly,
especially something which it was probably, and we're getting
ahead of ourselves here, it was probably a suppressed
5.56 round. If I had to guess, it was probably a 55 grain full
metal jacket. Judging by the small size of the exit wound on
the front of his neck, assuming it's an exit wound, assuming,
right, allegedly an exit wound, that 55 grain bullet's not displacing
much tissue, and it's not a heavy projectile in and of itself.
So, here you have a guy who understands the audio from all of
these different camera angles, all of these different >> Bro,
this guy went this guy went he debunked himself.
He There's no way he went and loaded up with even more
conspiracy theories. He went, "You know what, guys? Yeah, I got
everything wrong. Yeah, I'm totally full of shit." But hold on.
Let me look. I've reloaded. Okay, see all these guns behind me?
I know a thing or two about reloading. Okay, I've reloaded. I
got new bullets. Check this out. Check this out. to were filming
the event and using science to time exactly when that device
registered the sound and then circulating that back >> using
science. What's the science? >> One location and triangulating
it pretty much based off of that audio and all of it points back
to this area where the bush man was. Now, is that definitive?
No. But again, it's just another piece of information pointing
in that direction of the gunshot coming from. and he simply says,
"Even at the maximum error margin, a shot from the rooftop simply
does not match the audio." So, there you have it. Just another
piece of information pointing in the direction of the background
of Charlie. Now, let's go back to the original topic, the main
video that I put out. >> Oh, he's got Valhalla up here
now, too. >> Theory that >> Valhalla, if you guys
didn't see it, okay,
uh Valhalla, this guy had the what? Ballistics test showing it
wasn't a 30 odd six round. >> I was discussing. I want
to give Vala VFT a huge shout out on this cuz I think his analysis
was perfect. He talked about the new information from Jesse on
Fire, that new angle. And he also brought up my video and talked
about how this does not completely debunk this angle, right?
He also brought up the audio engineers uh triangulating and figuring
out that the shot most likely came from that back right near
the bush man near that area somewhere over there. And also he
pointed out that the entrance wound typically does not bleed,
especially not right away. So, what I originally thought was
blood splatter is in fact Charlie's necklace does not 100% negate
the theory that he was shot from his back, right? In fact, it
kind of verifies it even more.
>> Listen, the fact that I was totally wrong about every
essentially every piece of evidence I thought I had, the fact
that I was totally wrong, that doesn't disprove it. In fact,
it kind of proves it even more. No timer. Um, you guys are on
my time now, so I'll leave when I want to leave >> because
it's not blood. there's a more of a higher likelihood that it's
actually an entrance wound because again, entrance wounds don't
bleed the way that we saw the front of Charlie's neck bleeding.
Okay? So, if Charlie is hit right here in his hairline where
we're kind of alleging he's hit, you Well, hold on. The Superman
neck miracle thing, like Fox News published that story, which
is just silly. Okay? It's silly to publish that even if it's
real. It's like it's just goofy. But, um, but like you don't
have to say that that's proof of a conspiracy. I don't know.
I it's just I don't think it's proof of a conspiracy. That's
>> you wouldn't be able to see it from this grainy. Even
this new footage from Jesse on fire, it's way too grainy to tell
if there is a small 223 entrance hole because again the hole
would only be the size the diameter of the bullet. Even smaller
sometimes because the again the skin and the tissue is going
to kind of seal back up over itself. Not completely, but enough
to be slightly smaller than the diameter of the bullet that entered.
Okay. So again, I want to give a big shout out to Vaja VFT for
talking about this in a very objective
Legacy still in jail? What? Uh, we didn't look up I could have
probably looked up their arrest records today. We'll we'll do
an update on that tomorrow and I I would expect them both to
be out. Is Prawn out? Did Prawn manage to get out or you said
Legacy still in jail. So, does that mean Prawn's
Prawn's out or >> Wait, what did I miss? What did they
do now? Tourniquette, they on camera stole a GPU and tried to
hold it hostage. Okay, they were on camera when they stole the
GPU out of this roommate's bag. They packed up all the they put
at the front door and they went and stole a GPU out of his bag
and said he could have it back once he paid his back rent, right?
The cops showed up and they're like, "Okay, why is he saying
you stole this?" They're like, "Well, I don't know. We don't
know where it is." And then they're like, "He says he has a clip
of you guys stealing it." And they're like, "Well, if he's got
a clip, I don't know. I don't remember. I didn't do anything
like that." And Legacy and and Prawn are on video on a Chicken
Andy clip taking the GPU out of this guy's thing and saying they're
going to go hide it. And so the cops, the the guy, it was um
it was Squeeze who pressed charges. Yeah, Squeeze just said,
"Yeah, I'm going to press charges." And they they got arrested
and go to jail. It's
>> So, the next thing I want to discuss is Charlie's hair
jolting forward. I said that because he was hit in the back of
the head, his head kind of moved forward very quickly. His hair
was lying at rest and then it had been, you know, it kind of
had needed to catch up. And >> what rumors or something
that Bloius might be in jail for violating protective order?
I haven't fully read it in DRL. Dude, do we have anybody in Austin
who can validate any of this stuff? Who who can I talk to about
this?
I actually don't even know where is everybody.
All the people are gone. Oh, dude. And so you can see that clearly.
And when his hair his head jolts forward like that, you can see
his hair his head jolting forward from being struck from the
back. Could this be explained by a throat shot? I don't see it
quite that easy. If he had been hit in the chest, I could see
his chest going backwards and therefore his head going forward.
But you can see very clearly Charlie's head snaps down and to
his left. Um, could that be explained by the shot in the throat?
Yeah, it could. So, there you go. There's me playing devil's
advocate for you guys. I still think it points more to him getting
shot in the back right side of his head, but it is possible.
Now, the other thing I want to talk about is the exit wound and
the skin being pulled right here that I see. So, a lot of people
were trying to explain this as like the shirt was folded weird
or the shirt was creased or something like that, but as you can
see in the footage here, uh there is a black spot right there
that then corresponds with a black spot on Charlie's shirt directly
after the bullet exits
allegedly. So right there you can see it. You can see the exit
wound and then either a blood stain or a hole in the shirt from
the bullet pulling through. This is one of the biggest arguments
against my video as well in stating that you would not be able
to see the projectile because the the frame rate of a of a iPhone
is 30 frames per second. Now anybody who uses an iPhone knows
that new iPhones have incredibly good cameras. Now, they're not
high-speed cameras that can catch bullets flying typically, but
when a bullet strikes tissue and slows down to the point where
it has to travel from here to here, it's going to slow down significantly.
And I believe that what we saw, his skin stretching, may not
even have been the bullet. It may have been the bullet already
passed through and exited through his shirt or or just above
his shirt and continued traveling on. It may have very well been
his skin just hadn't had time to retract yet. Because as we all
know, when you watch high-speed footage of shooting through something
soft or elastic, you see it stretch and then after the projectile
passes through, then it starts to retract, but it still it lags
behind the projectile slightly. So, we could have caught just
his skin after the bullet already passed through. I'm not saying
we caught the bullet right as it was about to poke out of his
skin. I'm just saying it's a possibility, guys. Okay? And to
me, all of this is looking like the most possible scenario, as
many of you guys agree, right? because the video wouldn't have
done as well as it did if most of the people didn't actually
agree with what was being said. It makes the most
>> They agree with the video cuz they love conspiracies.
You are you are using your expertise, your reputation to tell
them there's a conspiracy happening and that you've picked the
most insane to say. That's why the video did well. Yeah. People
want to believe conspiracies. Absolutely. And then you use your
credibility to reinforce conspiracies that you are clearly you've
proven yourself wrong on. >> Sense I'm just asking you
to believe what your eyes are showing you, right? I'm just putting
it all together in a cohesive way and you guys all agree that
that is probably the most likely scenario, right? And I I do
as well, but I'm not married to this idea. Again, if I see new
information, I will correct the narrative. So, another thing
I want to address is the angle of the shot. So, I show this arrow
here as far as the bullet trajectory. This was just the simplest,
most direct line from entry to the exit. But most likely this
angle, this this angle of bullet is sitting up here in the tent
somewhere. You would not be able to actually Charlie or actually
see him to shoot him. And I don't believe he was shot blindly
through the tent. So most likely the trajectory is much flat.
>> Thank Yeah. Again, thank thank God, guys. Thank god
that we got Charlie's face Charlie's face blurred here. >> Like
this. This would be really offensive if we didn't have Charlie's
face blurred right now. >> Coming in from the side. >> Just
disgusting to tell you the truth. >> Hit his skull. And
as everybody's been saying to explain the magic bullet of of
2025, that it stopped at his spine. The man of steel. Bullets
do do weird things when they enter flesh. So, let me stop for
a moment and pause and say, is it possible it stopped at his
vertebrae?
One in a million. I'm not going to say that because I would just
be saying that to cover my own act and say, "Oh, well, anything's
possible." Yeah, anything is possible with the power of God.
But in this case, ballistics don't lie. I believe the bullet
probably came in from below the tarp of the tent, from this angle,
struck Charlie, and then did some weird things. Probably struck
him right around here around the base of his hairline. So, it's
much more likely the bull came in from this trajectory here,
hit the base of his hairline, hit the base of his stem and spinal
column, causing him to tense up, causing his head to go down
and to the left, and then kind >> Okay, but the only the
only views of this, sorry, the only angles of this with the the
like the tent, the back of the tent is closed. I feel like the
only angles on this, you see the entrance wound from the side
view, right? From the original side view he had, I feel like
you uh this one like this. Hold on. Can we I'll grab this time
stamp and we can just go back. But like don't wouldn't you see
the entrance wound >> You can see it's broken apart. >> So
I paused it here where you can see >> how in the world
would you not see the entrance wound? >> Believe that.
Um so most most likely what we see blow. >> Oh yeah. Also
the projector just kind of blown the thing out right now. >> And
what I was thinking and what I was calling blood splatter from
the back right side of Charlie's head is most likely his necklace.
And it looks and seems to me that it has broken apart. >> How
do you have this video?
How do you have this video and you still claim he got shot in
the back back of the head?
>> This is literally like in line with the angle that he
thinks this guy got hit from the back right of his head. This
is the video that would show the entrance
>> for right here. >> This is the video. Like it
would be right here. >> Let's let's let this skip ahead
a little bit and you'll see. >> Yeah. Anyway, so we'll
go back to the end here and >> kind of moved its way >> down
here and exited out the front here. So that is much more likely.
I put this here to kind of show the simp like for people who
don't understand what bullets do when they hit things. Uh the
simplest way to understand that just okay straight through. But
it's most likely uh his tarp his tent was above there. So no
one would have had the vantage point to actually hit him from
that angle. It was most likely a much more flat a much flat I
wouldn't say much flatter but a flatter trajectory because you
have to see what you're shooting at. Uh I don't think someone
took a blind shot through a tarp. So uh with that being said
or the cover of the tent I believe it was more more along the
lines of this angle here somewhere in this ballpark here and
it came in struck Charlie and then exited out here in the front.
So right here guys this is the footage I wanted to show you.
So you can see here in this video now could this be anything?
Could this be something flying off Charlie? Could this be a piece
of flesh, a piece of bone? Yeah, it could be for sure. But it
is just curious that it happens right at the moment after Charlie
is hit and he you can see that piece coming out of his neck.
So, you can clearly see something traveling between Charlie's
legs that many people are speculating is a projectile. So, again,
you can see that streak by right there. Multiple frames of this
video. And I do believe >> I would assume this could also
be the necklace to be honest with you. Like I would think it
could also be the necklace. Like that thing shattering might
send pieces flying off. It's like a linked necklace, right? >> That
is most likely the projectile because it correlates with everything
else that we've seen. So it's hard to tell if it's actually closer
to the camera than we're seeing. >> Wait, aren't you Wasn't
this guy just making a point about 30 frames per second? Couldn't
you based on how that streaks across the camera? Couldn't you
guess that thing's speed and it would be way less than an actual
bullet? Right. It's like streaking across the camera in video.
I don't think a bullet would show going across video frames.
>> But it does beg the question, why were >> like
that's going way slower than you would expect to go. Right. Hold
on.
>> So it's hard to tell.
>> Maybe you only see it for a couple frames. Maybe maybe
maybe >> closer to the camera than we're seeing. But it
does beg the question, why were there pavers installed in the
location where Charlie was sitting >> like immediately
like the next day after the shooting happened? >> It's
just again another piece of information for you guys to take
and chew on and just ask the question why. If there is any potential
there, >> this doesn't even show the trap door, >> The
second shooter. If there's any potential there may be still projectile
in the dirt around where Charlie was sitting, why in the world
are we putting pavers down? the beautifification of the of the
campus can wait until the investigation's over. People who say
that you cannot catch bullets on an iPhone or or at a frame rate
of 30 or 60 frames per second, uh that is just not true. Okay,
I understand the science behind it, but in reality, especially
something like this, something moving this slow after it's exited
a target, a medium of sorts, a a fluid target, we've had plenty
of videos you can find online of showing projectiles punching
through, you know, whether it be jugs of water or ballistics
gel, and you can see them travel on after they pass through the
medium. And uh in this case, I'll show you guys a video. You
can see the bullets flying, right? It depends on the angle of
the sun. If the bullets just catch it just right, it is certainly
possible to see. Now, yeah, obviously what people are saying
is that the bullet would be a streak, not a dot. Okay. Again,
not trying to prove or disprove anything. Just another piece
of information for you guys. This is a subsonic 300 blackout.
For your information, traveling approximately 1,000 to 1,50 ft
per second. Okay, 220 grain. Okay. So, >> so you can see
a clear as day on a regular camera that I'm filming on right
now. It's filming at 60 frames per second. Uh, it's not a high-speed
camera whatsoever. But I'll show you. Let's see if I can see
the POV footage of it. So, again, is it possible? Absolutely.
It is possible that that bullet was caught on camera. It's also
very possible it was not caught on camera. So, one last thing
I want to cover, guys, is FBI Director Cash Patel put out this
tweet, and this was on Dude, this Cash tweet is so stupid. How
did we miss this? I just didn't see this when it came out, man.
There's so much [__] going on. It's hard to catch
everything. How the does he go on his FBI head, the director
of the FBI Twitter account, he goes, "Guys, I'm going to address
every conspiracy theory I've seen online." Shockingly and perhaps
most tellingly, I see no acknowledgement of the trap door theory.
Zero. Nothing about projectors, nothing about the trapoor. Okay.
Cash is full of just got here. One thing I know or I know one
thing. 30 odd six loud as on September 21st. So 3 days ago as
of filming this video, he says, "As director of the FBI, I'm
committed to ensuring the investigation into Charlie Kirk's assassination
is thorough and exhaustive, pursuing every lead to its conclusion."
So right here he goes into we are meticulously investigating
theories and questions including the location of where the shot
was taken. Okay. So everyone who's asking me why am I questioning
it here you have the actual FBI director questioning this as
well. Okay. The possibility of accompllices, text message confession
and related conversations, Discord chats, angle of the shot and
bullet impact. Again, these are all things that we're talking
about and he's coming out and saying the FBI is investigating
it as well, which is promising. But when you have things like
the medical examiner coming out and saying that he was the man
of steel, >> the FBI isn't questioning it. That cash is
stupid,
dude. He's like, "Oh, we'll look into all of the stuff you guys
are suggesting we look into." It's already dumb to do that. It's
dumb to make any comment on an active investigation. But he's
like, "This is exact." He's just feeding into these now, right?
See you later, Kico. >> I kind of lose faith right away.
uh because if that's the official narrative, then my god, we
have we have some problems in this country. So, I wanted to take
this moment and take this opportunity to thank every single one
of you for being here, seeking the truth, seeking justice for
Charlie Kirk and for this country really. I think a lot of us
took it personally when they killed him because that could have
been any of us in fact and uh assassinating Charlie Kirk was
a direct attack on the first I took it so personally when they
killed Charlie Kirk that I decided to show him dying a thousand
times over the course of a week. Okay. That's how personally
I took it. I farmed a 7 million view video off of his corpse.
But I took it I took it incredibly personally. All right. It
was [__] up. It was [__] up. They shot
this guy >> amendment in my opinion. And that needs to
be protected at all costs. But I also want to take a moment to
say whoever did it wanted to sew division and distrust and paranoia
in our country. Make people think twice about speaking out, speaking
their mind, and having conversations. And so I think now more
than ever it is super important to protect free speech. is super
important to protect all of our civil rights instead of giving
up our rights for the illusion of safety and chasing the enemy
that we've made in our own mind or or our algorithms had made
against us and just remember that Charlie Kirk believed in Jesus
Christ and I do as well and Jesus Christ preaches the message
of loving thy neighbor. So I think it's super important to try
to get closer to Christ, try to forgive people, try to have some
nuance and oh I mean that's a good message at the end, right?
Hey uh lower this. He's basically lowering the temperature right
here. Okay. And closing it looks like closing the video. >> Try
to be the best person that you can be for for yourself, for your
family, for your country. With that being said, guys, I love
every single one of you. Thank you so much for staying to the
end of the video. If you guys do want to support the channel,
please head to rangebro.com.
Check out our discounts page, our loadouts page. >> I think
it's based to like at least if he was going to do nothing else
for him to at least go, hey, remember Jesus doesn't want you
to kill anybody. If that if that's like at least he's ending
on it, okay, I'm trying to give this guy any win he can get.
That was a rough video. The the bush man the bush man part is
particularly disgusting. Like that's just absurd. The bush man.
All right.
That's rough. Anyway,
all right guys, that's it for the stream. I'm going to raid out
to its like live. We'll throw you guys at IEO. You guys can watch
Ieko.
Looks like she's watching.
She's watching Queen I think. Quan video on YMS. So guys, go
check out IEO. And I'll be back will be back tomorrow. Have a
good one, guys. Good night. Enjoy your Friday.